Hello everybody!
Hello!
Hi!
You can tell like when I swapped a like Chinese accent with
my hello.
Hello!
You're getting in the mood already?
Yeah, getting in the mood.
It's been a while since I've like spoke.
Well that's not true because I speak Chinese.
Really?
How long?
Well, I speak Chinese to my parents.
like um oh really then you're like an expert aren't you no i
am not no no no you actually know how to read and write
that's different what you mean but you speak to your parents
in chinese i speak to my parents in english bro i like okay
no no no no because like i speak like like like elementary
school chinese though really no i doubt it nah yeah because
they're like what do you want to eat I'll be like I want to
eat this I think you know I think you're gonna teach me some
words today.
I don't know.
I'm scared now I was yeah, I was like, okay Let me let me
think what I can mmm slang words.
Yeah What I heard Curse words words Chinese curse words I
mean, isn't that like the first thing everybody learns
that's true in every language You learn like the curse words
for every language that is so true you want to curse out
your teammates a little yeah that's true by the way guys
hira and i were like talking before we're like in the in the
starting stream she has she streamed 16 hours yesterday
because of apex and hong kai i was like yeah i i was i was
going crazy last night it was really it was crazy because i
really did not expect like the Hongkai story to be like that
long the update so I was like okay I stream Apex you know
what it updated I'm gonna play it for a little while and
then pick him night oh my gosh wait so like I've asked to do
this but how much money have you spent on Hongkai uh wait
yeah oh I don't know do you have how many characters do you
have on Hongkai let me see let me see i i think i can open
my game right now wait let me let me check wait because
ditto has 37 now apparently that's the total right is that
the total amount of characters hanka has she has 37 that's
kind of that's a lot you bet that's a lot but i have more i
have wait you have 47?
There's 40 and total.
There's 48 in total.
Yeah.
I like I played since the beginning, but I also took a break
for like six months and I came back two months ago, I think.
Oh, okay.
So like so then you have to catch up after taking a break
and then you got so the only characters you're missing are
the ones that you didn't get when you were at break, right?
Yeah!
Because I was collecting all of them and then after that I
was like, oh crap.
I have like so much, like so many other games to play.
So I was like, okay, I gotta take a break from that.
And like six months later I came back.
I'm like, oh, I really want to play it.
I really want to play it.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what other gotcha games do you play other than Han
Kai?
Now?
Yeah.
Well, actually none other.
Because it's expensive, okay?
Like, gotcha games are expensive.
Yeah, you only...
Like, if you play more than, like...
I think 2 is, like, the maximum anybody should have.
Because, like, 1 is, like, crazy.
If you spend, like, a little bit on it, like, it's...
Now for, like, a month or two months, you know what I mean?
Yeah!
It's crazy.
So, I only play Hongkai now.
But I played Genshin 2 before.
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait.
How many characters do you have in...
Genshin then.
Don't ask.
I had like three accounts, dude.
I had like three accounts.
So...
They're both like, they're all from like the same company
too, right?
Me, Mihoio?
Yeah, it's Mihoio.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, they're... They have like...
They have like the algorithm or like the the structure of
its set.
I played... I played like Hongkai Impact third of that one.
Yeah, I played that one too, that's why.
Oh, wait.
Are you talking about Honkai Star Rail?
Yeah.
Yeah, the one before that is, like, part of the Honkai
series.
Wait, what's the difference between Honkai Impact and Honkai
Star Rail?
Honkai Impact is waifu-only, basically.
Waifu-only, yeah.
Yeah, it's basically waifu-only.
Okay, oh, so Star Rail has men.
Yeah.
It's part of, like, the same universe.
I see.
But it's fun.
But I know.
And like, I heard like Star Rail is sort of like similar to
like Genshin, like the open world right?
It's similar but like not similar at the same time.
It's like actually really not similar.
I think Genshin is tired.
Sorry to say it's a little bit tiring because like you have
to do everything manually.
Yeah.
But like in Star Rail you can kind of like leave your home.
phone there or leave it going and like you'll be like okay
type yeah yeah relax while looking at it i see you see i i
don't know anything about like gotcha games in general uh
because like for me i'm also scared of getting addicted it
is it is addictive i try not to play any gotcha game because
like i'm scared of getting addicted and i'm scared when i
get addicted that i'm gonna money yeah I think that's the
problem everybody has like damn that that woman is so hot
that god like I must have you know it's like wow yeah
because I already spend money on fortnite skins and like
it's it's a problem yeah I don't even fortnite skins yes
fortnite skins because it's funny like peter griffin like I
have peter griffin john cena Dragon Ball Z.
I have the, like, emo dance on it.
I have Ganymede style.
Really?
Because it's fun.
I only touched Fortnite, like, once ever.
And I was like, whoa.
I don't, I don't, like, buy the skins to play with it.
I buy the skins, like, just because I think it's funny.
Like, I don't even play Fortnite.
Wait, you don't play it?
You don't play if you buy the skins?
I only play it on stream.
I only play it.
I really feel like But it's funny It's like how you see like
You see the pretty characters And you're like Oh they're so
pretty You know what I can't judge you I see the funny
Fortnite skin I'm like Oh it's so funny Well yeah I get it
Well Yeah I get it You know what I can't judge you Because
Financial choices you know Because you don't like gacha
games So you can like Yeah exactly I saved my money Yeah by
not playing gacha games.
And instead, I spend that money I save from gacha games to
buy Fortnite skins.
I don't know which is the lesser evil.
Honestly, it's the game.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, we don't know what's the lesser evil.
But we both spend money irresponsibly.
It's true.
But you know what?
Wifu for lifu, right?
I haven't heard that in like years Until the game Until like
in 10 years The game gets shut down For Genshin Impact For
the sequel of Genshin Impact No Dude that's so sad
Eventually your waifus Your waifus will disappear You know
because the servers Will get shut down That's what happens
to like so many games that's why it's so scary that's why i
don't do gacha too because of the server i feel like servers
tend to get shut down due for gacha games eventually and
then all those waifus all those digital waifus will be gone
because they're not real but the mihoyo is pretty good at
keeping like that's true mihoyo i don't see like an end to
it you know what i mean yeah i feel like mihoyo It's sort of
like, um, it's sort of like Riot where it's like, like
League of Legends will never die.
So I feel like me.
Yeah, League of Legends actually, I never learn how to play
League.
So I was like learning how to play it.
And it's crazy.
It's like too many heroes in it.
And I'm like, dude, what does this guy do?
What are the combos?
I'm saying there's like a hundred heroes.
Yeah.
It's really difficult actually.
I was like that's why I could never learn league and also
because like it's so fucking toxic too.
So Yeah, yeah, it's really toxic.
I heard like yeah, yeah, what are you gonna say?
No, you can go ahead.
No, okay.
I heard from my friends that the the moderating team for
league is so intense now that you say anything toxic they'll
like ban you instantly.
So people got like super creative on how to be toxic to each
other.
Wait, really?
Yeah, yeah, they'll be like super passive-aggressive.
Like, you did a good job when they clearly didn't do a good
job.
So, just to get away from the...
Just to get away from the filters and the bands, they'll
just be like super passive-aggressive.
Oh, yeah, so it's like, good job, smile.
Yeah.
It's just another level.
Oh, wait.
Is this what you meant when your mic was going to cut off?
I see your mouth moving.
Oh, okay, guys.
Hiro's mic is...
Hiro's mic started cutting off.
Now she's just mute now.
Is this Chinese?
Sorry, we got carried away with speaking English.
Oh.
Whoa, are you okay?
Welcome back Wait, never mind Okay, welcome back Never mind
See my problem It's crazy This thing is like crazy Okay, I
gotta Whoa, she's gotta We'll never know We'll never know
She might have to be a PNG guys Like her apparently her PC
Fucking exploded And I was like What
so like goodbye she's gone it's like i could hear her voice
suddenly the scum is always she's gonna be a png guys her pc
is fighting with her see i'm not the only one with pc issues
okay guys all vtubers have similar problems okay i'm not i'm
not the only On my back.
Oh, your back.
You're back.
Yeah, God.
Oh, yeah, that's scary.
It's so scary.
You just suddenly stopped talking.
I was like, you know, like, it's only when I screen share.
It's so annoying.
That's so weird.
Yeah, like, Discord screen share, like anything else, like,
it's all fine.
Like, everything is all fine except screen share.
It's so annoying.
That's so weird.
All my USB, you know, my keyboard, my mouse, my... Like,
everything else just...
My mic?
Yeah.
It just stops working, right?
Yeah, yeah.
You sent me a PNG.
Yeah.
I can put it on the screen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, guys.
She, uh, we're just waiting until the PNG comes back.
What were you going to say about League?
You know?
League?
Yeah.
Well, League, I actually am going.
I think there's like competitions.
Like, I think there's a big competition.
soon or something.
I'm going to be doing a watchalong for League or something.
Oh, yeah.
Like, is it like an eSport or?
Yeah, it is the eSport tournament.
I'm not sure which one it is because I don't follow League
too much.
Apparently it's like MSI?
I think so.
I'm not sure.
But, like, because of that too, I'm like, oh crap.
I really got to learn, like, you got to know what's going
on.
I don't know what's going on.
It's just really difficult to like, you know, actually
Chinese is like not my mother language as well.
You know, right?
You know, English, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
How did you, how did you get so good at Chinese?
I have to, actually I used to stream like every day in
English and then like I converted.
As soon as I went on Biddy Biddy, I like just stream in
Chinese every day just to practice.
Just to practice, yeah.
like so scared because i can't read chat you know i could
only read chat in like english before yeah so i was really
like oh crap i can't understand anything at all so i was
like okay i gotta learn chinese just read chat oh my god
you're like you're like so you have like the brain capacity
for like language learning because you know like japanese
too right yeah you can you speak japanese sort of fluently
yeah i i that that's also like i learned it since like young
as well oh my god i used to learn like a lot uh like
japanese and chinese like that's insane oh my gosh that's
like like language learning is like one of the hardest
skills to have because like you actually need like it's a
part of your sector in your brain like section in your brain
for every day okay that good a good good question
That's a good question.
Yeah, I kind of want to hear you speak Chinese, actually.
I was kind of excited.
Oh, speak Chinese?
All right.
Wait, okay.
I feel like words.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's so long since I spoke like Mandarin as well.
Yeah, I'm like, wow.
mattering before to you like a long time ago yeah yeah wait
i don't even remember that's how long it was that's i like
how like you're not on the screen so it looks like i'm just
talking to myself like i'm i'm talking to the voices in my
head yeah i'm like trying to find like the voices in my head
no no no i'm i'm i'm a ghost Oh my god.
She's haunting me.
Wei?
Yeah.
Your Chinese is great.
What do you mean?
I said one word.
Yeah.
One word.
Oh my god.
You're a natural.
Wow.
Yeah, your Chinese is way.
Yeah, better than me.
That's not true.
I can't even read her right.
I stopped learning Chinese.
like I stopped like having like teachers for Chinese since
like third grade yeah because like okay that's a long time
exactly because like because my parents were like was we're
like I think like oh yeah because like I moved I moved out
of Canada um and I moved to Asia and then like we had a
choice I had a choice between like oh like learn Chinese or
learn French And then my parents were like you're Canadian
You should learn French and we'll talk to you in Chinese So
you can get double Yeah, yeah Learn French until like I
graduated high school So like they're like you have to learn
you should learn French We will talk to you in Chinese So
that's gonna be how you're learning it I was like okay So I
never learned how to I never like the only thing I know how
to read like right are like you know like like the basics
for like chinese like like um like cat dog mom dad like i
know how to write horse like your spoken chinese is like way
better isn't it well like it's because like you okay is you
know how like okay because like i lived in i lived in like
china as well so like i don't know like you know uh like the
like the shows there so i would just like watch random shows
that would pop up on tv oh and then like i have nothing to
do so like i would i would just like watch the show so like
you know when you listen to a lot of shows yeah then you can
sort of like understand actually yeah that's that's a lot of
like how i learn as well yeah yeah i like to i like to watch
stuff watch videos yeah yeah so like you know there's
nothing else playing on tv so i just like like i'll just
like be watching random tv shows And then, I just slowly
build up Like speaking wise But then I still have like Like
um I had like I don't I never really liked speaking
Cantonese like Um in high school Cantonese Yeah I know I can
speak like Mandarin and Cantonese like much so Cantonese
Cause I speak Cantonese at home But like I like at high
school I didn't like speaking Cantonese Like out loud
Because like my friends would make fun of me Because I
haven't Because I have an English accent when I...
Because, like, you know, in Chinese, there's different
tones.
And it's, like, very strict.
Like, the tonation.
Yeah.
It's extremely strict.
Yeah, yeah.
So, like, I didn't care about that.
So, you know, I'd be, like, speaking...
Like, if I had a question, I'll speak in the English tone
for questions and stuff.
So I don't, like, follow the...
I don't follow the...
that problem a lot too like I try and fix it as much as I
can but like because we speak in English so often so yeah
it's like yeah I did this this fluctuation isn't it yeah
yeah that's that's like a problem for me too yeah and then
and then like my chat will make fun of me yeah yeah so like
that's why I was like so then like I wouldn't speak I rarely
speak um like uh Chinese in public Because, like, they would
just keep making fun of me.
They're like, say it again!
Say it again!
And I'll be like, no!
I'll be like, no!
You're just gonna make fun of me!
Well, it's actually really cute!
You heard me say one word.
What do you mean?
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
All right.
Okay, well, let's try to have a conversation.
You start.
You go first.
Okay.
And then see what I can understand it.
I think you can Like what am I gonna talk about?
Wait, you know Yeah Today's the weather is really nice Just
be like Just ask you how the weather is really nice Is that
like?
Oh yeah The classic Classic conversations Wow, yeah Today's
Really good Wait!
Oh my god, okay.
Usually, you only speak in English, right?
Usually.
Yeah, usually.
Well, like to my parents, I speak in Cantonese.
And like, it's because like...
I want to hear you speak Cantonese.
Wait, do you understand Cantonese?
So, okay.
So I actually did not understand Cantonese for a long time.
Then I learned a little bit from like videos and also being
on Vidi Vidi.
And also I stay...
Do you know where I live right now?
I'm like, okay, so I'm actually, I'm like Japanese, but I
stay in Malaysia.
Oh, wait, that's so interesting.
Wait, do you know Malaysian then?
The local language, yeah, a little bit.
Oh, that's so interesting.
Wait, so you're like super multilingual then.
Yeah, yeah, I can kind of speak, like, how do I say, like,
people here mix your, like, languages.
really often yeah yeah yeah so it'll mix english with canto
and stuff like that yeah yeah so that's why like i hear like
a lot of things every day so i'm like okay i can i can kind
of understand that's similar to me because like i learned
cantonese first and then but like uh my extended family
mostly speaks uh like on my on my dad's side mostly speaks
like manner in and then like growing up, I stayed with my
grandpa for a bit as well.
My grandpa only speaks like Mandarin, but he could like
understand Cantonese and stuff.
So then he'll like talk to me in Mandarin.
That's how I like learned like Mandarin because like people
just like talk to me in that in Mandarin instead of
Cantonese.
And then your spoken is so good.
And when you try and like read and write, it's like crap.
Oh, yeah, sure.
Like I can't read or write.
So before I would like, I remember when I first did like, I
try to speak stream and then people were like typing to me
in chinese really you did look i tried to speak yeah yeah i
did like for like a solo and then people were like typing to
me in chinese i was like i'm sorry i cannot read this like
you guys have to type to me in english you want to try again
well you can read it you can read it for me yeah i can
barely read english let alone like i can barely read english
let alone chinese
I can't read after that.
Someone in my chat was like, And then I don't know whatever,
what else?
Yeah, my traditional Chinese is crap.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know, like, traditional and simplified.
Yeah.
I think in Malaysia, they use simplified as well.
So my traditional is really bad.
Like, I'm trying to read it.
I'm like, crap.
Easier to learn traditional.
Well, I mean, traditional is, like, really difficult.
Because, like, that's why it's simplified.
Yeah!
But, like, when you know traditional, you can tell what is
the simplified version because you know you're like wait
that sort of looks like the traditional version and um i
learned traditional in canada i learned traditional so like
and then i remember like i remember oh wait no i did like
when i like when i like moved uh overseas i remember like
like i had one i think like i had like one lesson in like um
simplified and then I was like what I like I was right like
they're like write this sentence so that I wrote it in like
traditional and they're like what is this And I was like I
was like yeah, this is me Like like okay, so there is
traditional but the traditional is very it's like much
harder That's why yeah, because there's more strokes in it
You know how I learned like when I went to Biddy Biddy at
first I learned using Duolingo as well So I was like I'm
gonna use dual lingo is not like a good like learning like
not like a good like main learning tool type I was like very
confused on where to learn I was like okay you know what I'm
gonna open dual lingo I think like Chinese is like one of
the hardest languages to learn because of how many
intonations and like characters there are for like writing
and reading as well
i just just is like i don't know like cantonese has like
more intimate like more tones than like uh mandarin i don't
remember it was like eight or something like oh yeah there's
like a lot of chinese dialects i think like i i don't know
how many do you know the chinese tongue twister wait which
one the one with like one character like one uh who is that
one like it sounds like the same same but it means different
things God what one was that one Oh the Shish Yeah That one
I hate it I don't know But like when I first learned Chinese
I think like people love to hear Like like new beginners
Making mistakes or something And they forced me to read All
those tongue twisters And like I was going crazy I was I was
like What?
What?
And then what?
I'm like, I'm like, no, I can't read this.
No.
Try it.
Try one.
Try one of them.
What?
Oh, let me, let me, let me see.
Is there any like easy tongue twister?
If it's a tongue twister, it's not meant to be easy.
There's one of a milk as well.
I remember just like some, some.
Yeah.
What's the milk one called?
Like, nai nai, new nai, something like that.
Nai, new nai.
I don't remember.
Like, there's a lot of tongue twisters.
It's too difficult, I think.
Maybe you can try.
You know what?
I can't even read.
What do you mean?
How do I do tongue twisters?
And I can't even read.
It's so difficult, honestly.
Tongue twisters, I think, in any language is difficult.
Some, like, English ones are pretty difficult.
There's some really difficult ones as well.
Well, I think, like, I think the Chinese ones are, like,
more so, like, the whole fact that, like, it sounds the
same.
It all sounds very similar, but it's all different meaning.
Yeah, so you, it's, like, basically, like, it's testing
your, your tonation reading type deal.
There's so much.
Stop avoiding the Chinese tongue twister.
Stop avoiding it.
I've gone through, like, torture doing those tongue
twisters.
Like, every single time I do a collab with, like, like,
like, like, oh, Hiro, we'll teach you Chinese today.
And then they always give me a tongue twister.
I can't take it.
And I'm like, Hiro teach me Chinese.
And I was like, Hiro, teach me Chinese.
Anyway, do a tongue twister too.
Yeah.
Well.
Okay, so wait, actually teach you something today like
useful things like you want to learn like slang or something
Yeah, yeah, yeah, teach me some some modern slang But you
well, you might know the slang if you talk to your parents.
Oh, no, I don't like I don't progress What I don't I don't
progress that is I'm like stuck in this time chamber of The
Chinese I've known I Like, I never learn anything new.
Just asking, do you want to learn curse words or do you know
all the curse words already?
I feel like I know a lot of the curse words already because,
like, you know, like when your parents are driving the car
and they start yelling at the drivers in the car.
What?
Wow, what did they yell?
I'm so interested.
My mom watches my street.
Wait, really?
Yeah, but I learned...
Wait, wait.
I...
Oh, okay.
But it's okay, right?
Like, you learn it from your parents.
Yeah, that's true.
No, that's true!
Yeah.
You can tell me one, I'll tell you one.
I...
I think the easiest one is like, I think everybody knows is
like the Chao Nima Oh, Chao Nima Yeah, Chao Nima Oh, no!
Yeah!
But it's like And then I know, okay, this one I've heard of
that one Yes, I've heard of that one And then Well, the most
tame one is The most tame one is Bapol, which is like Bitch,
so Well, yeah, that's pretty tame.
Yeah, it's pretty tame.
There's a lot of things I could say, but Bapol is the tame
one.
They love the curse.
I would say, actually, Chinese, there's a lot of different
ways you can curse somebody.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, like, I know, like, when I was growing up, my mom
would be like, so it's like, having a pork bun is better
than having you.
What?
Wait, really?
Wow!
Oh my god!
It's like, it's like one of the most common.
That's one of the most...
Yes, it's a very common.
It's a very common, like, Cantonese thing to say.
Santasu Hoko Sanne.
Do you...
Like, I would...
Like, it's pretty tame.
It's tame, though.
There's a lot of cursors that have, like, abbreviations,
too, do you know?
Like, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's like WD, NMD, SV.
Then, like, the Chaonima is like, like, they also go, like,
WOC for, like, all those, like, short form stuff.
Yeah, yeah, oh, yeah, yeah.
I actually don't know a lot of the short form stuff,
because, like, I don't know, a lot of, like, the Chinese
stuff were, like, on the internet type.
deal like internet slang and in chinese um like i think like
a lot of it was internet slang yeah
in english i learned it's also like from movies too so like
you know like the slang from in movies and stuff but like
it's also old movies like like okay i don't really care his
name in in Mandarin but like you know like Zhao Xing T like
Stephen Stephen Chow and that's his name oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so like i would watch like he would say stuff
like the this Cantonese slang too so like i would like
repeat what he would say so Wait, what do you...
Well, okay.
That's where you're Chinese.
Okay, I got it.
Wait, what do you mean?
I got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's where you're in your Chinese.
Really?
He has good, really good movies, okay?
True.
Yeah, learn from the best.
Well, there's like...
Well, I think you know enough curse words, but like...
Um...
I was...
say like the short form like i see a lot of like you know
like i said earlier like like um and like and yeah nmsl like
nmsl like nima's like and almost like like things
so they'd love to like put all those short forms out on the
internet and usually you won't understand because it looks
like you know like a gibberish basically Oh, yeah.
Wait, it looks like gibberish?
I mean, you won't understand.
If you don't know Chinese, you won't understand at all.
Yeah, but there's like cute ones too.
Wait, where are the cute ones?
Yeah, I saw like, AWSL is actually something really cute.
Like, usually, yeah, a lot of, like, when I first went to
Bididid, they all, like, used to say that to me all the
time.
AWS is like, ah, I'm sorry, in a good way.
Ah, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
No, it's me, it's like I'm dead but like in a good way.
Oh, oh so you're so cute that I'm dead.
Yeah, you're so cute.
At first I was like, what?
Oh, I was s-a-o-a-a-w-a-s-oh wait that's actually really
cute.
Yeah, yeah, it's from like how cute you are.
It's actually really cute.
That's so cute actually.
Oh, but even your cute words are like kind of like morbid
you know.
It's like I'm dead.
AWSL and they quote unquote affectionate
they they like to say like like sǐ le a lot like she she see
she sǐ le you know like she what is she like she like I'm
angry to death kind of thing because I'm dead from anger
like yeah yeah yeah yeah like I like sǐ le like I'm no idea
why though.
Yeah, I learned a lot of like this thing.
Yeah, I learned a lot of like slang.
That's actually, that's yeah.
That's so cute.
AWSL, that's going to be my vocabulary now.
I'm just going to be like AWSL.
It's like, it's like Tashkaru, right?
Yeah, yeah, that's what I was thinking.
It's like similar to Tashkaru.
They like to say KKSK as well.
Kokosuki.
What's that mean?
I like Kokosuki is like I like this point in Japanese like
Tuscaru and KKSK Oh That's so interesting Yeah TSKR and KKSK
They say KKSK more Kokosuki Kokosuki Wait what do you guys
use for like laughing On the internet?
Yeah They Okay they just spam a bunch of itch And they like
like just the letter itch or two three 33333 The numbers
Yeah 2333333 What does that mean?
It's just laughing Wait But that's like 2 Er San San San
Okay The 2333 thing Is like I think it's like I don't know
if it's like Biddy Biddy only No I don't think it's Biddy
Biddy only But like it originates Some Something from Biddy
It's because like Their mascot is called Like 2 and 3 Or
something like that taken.
And like HHH is just ha ha ha ha ha but they just spam like
a bunch of H.
Oh yeah.
So instead of like typing ha ha ha ha ha ha.
And it's like HHH.
It's like W W W.
You know in Japanese they just spam a bunch of Ws.
Yeah and they're like So like for like the Chinese
equivalents like HHH, HHH.
Yeah they also spam it.
That's so interesting.
That's really interesting.
Do you guys have anything like like Lamou?
So Lamou and Lul is basically H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H-H It's also
Shout-S-L-L Who's that?
It's like shout-S-L-L It's all It's all deaf, okay?
Like, I don't know Like, yeah, it's just like I just laugh
like Like La-Sit-Dead So it's like It's like It's all short
form, yeah Yeah, XS-S-W-L Like, yeah That's so interesting
A-W-S-L X-S-W-L Like, it's all, they all abbreviate it,
basically.
That's so interesting.
I never knew that.
This is what I mean.
I don't know anything about, like, like, the internet in
terms of, like...
He don't know any...
Okay.
Are you like...
Like, I don't...
I am...
Okay, you can say that I might be, like, a boomer when it
comes to, like, Chinese.
Like...
I don't know.
I don't know any of the, like, the hip things, you know?
What do the...
What do the young insane this time?
Look, if I grew up with like Zhao Sing Teeth, and like...
He's like 50 now.
He's like 50 to 60 now.
And like he hasn't made any...
I don't know, does he...
Has he made new movies?
I don't know.
But like, I haven't watched any of his new year movies.
I only know him, I think.
Like, I'm like...
Wow, I feel like I'm really talking to...
Like a grandma.
Ayy.
Like, auntie.
Auntie.
No.
I'm young when it comes to like English internet guys, I
swear.
Are you just gonna like say all this like, like, Like, uh,
whatever they say nowadays, just to appease everybody.
Yeah, for sure.
Nice dream, guys.
Not that old.
Well.
I swear.
I just don't.
I just, I, what do people, what do people watch now?
I don't know.
What do people watch in Chinese now?
I just don't, I didn't, I only remember, like, the old shows
when I used to watch, like, I was growing.
up like i know you don't know this show but like super it
was like this like variety show um it was like this variety
show uh on i think it was on tvb and like i like grew up
watching and it's like super it's like this like variety
competitions and stuff um with like celebrities and stuff
and like that was like i would watch that a lot too but that
is so old i don't even know if they still I've never heard
what is TVB TVB so it's like a it's a channel in uh in Hong
Kong uh TVB so um yeah and I see yeah yeah so it's like TVB
and Pearl I think that was like Pearl would show like the
English shows and TVB would be like the Cantonese shows oh
yeah super trio yeah they have a YouTube channel I know I
saw they I was watching their YouTube channel and everything
I was Like, I grew up watching, like, a lot of the shows on
TVB, and then a lot of the...
And then I would watch, like, Shroom Hong.
Like, you know, like, have you ever seen, like...
Oh, wait, no, because you don't watch the old shows.
You know?
Hero's, like, the zoomer.
I do feel like a zoomer, so...
Yeah, yeah, she's like the internet zoomer.
I don't know what she's talking about, but sounds great.
Wait, have you ever watched like the the Chinese show the
Shroom Hong?
Wait, how do you pronounce that in Mandarin?
Uh, what's that?
The monkey, the, the...
Oh, Xiu Ji?
Xiu Ji?
Is that the monkey king?
Yeah, okay, I watched it on, like, together with my, with my
fans.
Oh, but which version though?
There's so many.
The old one.
The real, oh, the really famous one?
The 19th, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The old, yeah, the old.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I watched that one.
Oh, it's so good.
It is really good.
I watched that.
I actually like that.
Yeah, and I watched that with my grandpa when I was like
growing up, like on the TV together.
Oh, that's so cute.
Yeah, because they would always have like reruns because
it's so famous.
I did watch it in 1980s, guys.
There were reruns.
I would watch, I would watch the reruns with my grandpa.
I was an older one.
I'm not sure.
It was in 1980s, isn't it?
I'm pretty sure, right?
It may be that one.
I remembered it wrong, I think.
But yeah, it's the one.
It's the OG one, I think.
So, yeah.
There's like a new one, but I like the old one better.
Yeah, yeah.
I think it's because it's a classic, too.
It's like a...
I think it's like one of the most famous TV shows they made
back then.
It's like the four classic There's so many It's like It's
like That Soji is one And then San Guo San Guo Is the other
one Uh Three kingdoms Yeah Yeah San Goji Yeah I love Three
kingdoms Oh my god I actually visited The temples For it I
visited Um I visited like Lou Bay's temple Uh Because I was
like No I was so I was so obsessed With like San Goji Like
It was like My life i actually read the original book yeah
no like i actually read the original yeah yeah i read the
original book i was like way too young to read this that
book by the way i because it was like it's like it's like
it's like two copies and they're like extra thick too so um
because i love the games that it was like the the three
kingdom that dynasty warrior games and through dynasty
warriors i start i really liked the stories behind it so
then i read the books as well and then i visited the temples
um like with my grandpa and my family wow yeah so like i
actually went to see like lube and chukolan the temple and
um i heard like tao tao temple was recently discovered too
and like and yeah they have a museum i really want to go
there it was like recently discovered Because like Chao
Chao, I don't even know about like the history behind it,
but like like Chao Chao's like temple slash like like Like
grave was like super hidden and stuff.
So he has like he has like fake graves so people won't like
rob it.
And like recently they recently discovered like his actual
like tomb and and people but like people are like no that
can't be his that has to be his son but people were like no
this has to be like chow chow's tomb because and then so
they made like a whole museum based off of it that recently
opened i think like two years ago or last year and wow i i
didn't know that honestly i'm like wow really yeah i never
knew that yeah yeah because i just i just like watched the
the tv version basically oh there's so many which one did
you watch i'm like crap i can't remember because it was like
two three years ago too early i think at this point um it's
just all the old ones basically the og ones i remember when
okay do you see the the red cliff movie have you watched the
red cliff movie it's like it's like i watched that at the
theaters in china wait isn't it theater yeah it's not old
i'm not that that movie came out like 10 years ago but
but it's not that it's not that old
I haven't even seen that I've actually seen that in theaters
I think like when the first week it came out because like
also it's because like the actor that played Chikotland He's
like apparently like back then he was like super famous and
then like my grandma like had a crush on that actor So like
my grandma like bought like My grandma bought me and her and
like I think like my dad like VIP seats to like watch the
Watch the movie During like opening Yeah It's actually
really interesting.
I don't think, like, my grandparents, I don't think they
were ever, like, watching that many movies, actually.
So I never really went to theater, like, to buy seats or
anything.
I've never had that.
Have you ever been in a theater in China, like, a movie
theater in China?
No.
Oh, my gosh.
I've only come to China once so far.
It's actually, wait, when did you go to China?
Like, when was the last time you went to China?
Actually, I went in March.
Oh, yeah, what did you do?
Wait, where did you go?
Wait, unless that's a Docs.
Shang, oh, Shang Hai!
It's okay!
Yeah, I did a 3D.
I did a 3D live, that's why.
Yeah, so you went to Shanghai for your 3D?
Yeah, I went to their studio.
That's why.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
Like, I went to visit the Biddy Biddy HQ.
Oh, oh my gosh.
What's it like?
It's actually really cool.
It's actually much nicer.
Like, I was kind of scared because, you know, my mother
language is also English.
And I was like, okay, my Chinese is like kind of, you know,
I don't know, like, I was like kind of scared going there.
But like, it was actually really nice.
Like, it was really interesting.
Oh, that's really, that's really cool, though.
You had to see their headquarters.
It's pretty English friendly.
So I was like, okay, thank God.
It's like, if I don't understand, I'll speak English.
That's really sweet.
But like, you never been to like a theater in China, right?
Like a movie theater?
No, I've not gone to a theater.
Really nice.
Because like, I think like the seats are...
I think like back then when I went to the movie theater,
like back then in NA, you don't have like seats reservations
in NA.
So it's like in NA when you want to go to a movie theater.
I think now people can reserve seats but back then like when
I was like a lot younger it was like a battle royale for
like getting good seats yeah yeah it was like you you have
to get there early if you want uh if you want to have like
good seats it's like a free-for-all so like people would be
like actually get to the theaters early just to like watch
it like if it was like a really good movie and like people
like really want to watch it like if you don't get there
early you have sit at the very front or something but i
don't know but i don't know now honestly like i haven't been
with movie theater for a long time anyway i remember when i
like you know when i started to live in asia and like in
china too um when i first came in theater you i was like oh
my god you get to reserve seats oh my god you mean i don't
have to come to the theater 30 minutes early just to sit in
a good spot like i'm getting convinced you're you're you're
are becoming like, like, like grandma.
You know what?
That's true!
On TV, this is great.
Yeah.
And then...
What you're saying to me is, I'm like, wait, really?
Have you ever heard?
No, it's true!
Look, I came from a place where there was a battle royale
for movies.
There's some smell.
And then, but then like, also like, I think, I don't, I
think now they have buttered popcorn, but like, I remember
like, like popcorn.
back then was only caramel popcorn back then but i don't
know what like well like all the like parents and grandmas
and grandpas say though like like even when they go anywhere
do you always say it's like it's like it's like they went on
like a journey it's like so difficult to do anything yeah
even going to the movie theater it's like that's a VR but
like I remember there's like the feet but like there's like
VIP movie theaters too where like um oh my gosh where
there's only like uh 15 seats or whatever like 15 chairs and
they're all like recliners look this is it's true I went to
like I like my grandma was like up like loves movies and
then like like and then because like I was like um so like
in in Chinese culture like I was like the first born
grandchild with like the the last name because I wasn't the
first born grandchild technically because I had like cousins
older than me but I was the first one that came from that
has like my last name was like basically like the last name
of my grandparents so like so then they were like okay we
have VIP movie tickets we take Doki to because so i get to
like i get to like so i was like considered like the
favorite child the favorite grandchild because of it yeah
yeah the the favorite grandchild and the firstborn perks and
and then and then so like i got to do like the i got to i
got to do like see like the the vip movie theaters and it
was crazy because like first off like the chairs are
recliners and then and then like and then like you don't
have to go to the you don't have to go to like to outside to
order the food you can just like like there's like movie
theater tenants that come to you and be like what do you
it's like a like a flight attendant like what do you want to
eat and then they'll be like okay i'll have this and that
and then they'll like go and then they'll like make it and
it'll bring it to you yeah back then this is like this is
like crazy already huh like and then like a lot of like and
it's not like a lot of like the bigger movie theaters had
had like a VIP section too but it was like so yeah I watched
the red cliff on the VIP movie theaters are you flexing like
I'm like listening hmm favorite The red clip was a good
movie!
It was so good!
It deserved to be in the VIP section.
I wish I was the favorite grandchild.
Yeah.
It was nice.
And then like, and then I like, and I remember I went back
to Canada and then the movie theaters was still still the
battle royale.
I'll tell that story in Chinese.
Okay, then...
That's Cantonese!
Okay, my Cantonese is I can listen, I can understand, but
like, I can't speak at all, I think.
I can only listen a little bit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What is like, do you know a sentence in Cantonese?
I just said I can't speak it at all.
You said you know a little bit.
I can listen, yeah.
I only know memes, basically.
Wait, like what memes?
I don't even know the memes.
That meme?
Wait, what is that?
No, I just don't like...
You don't know?
No, what is that meme?
There's like a video.
I think it's on video, if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah, it's like, it's like, it's 3 p.m.
Like, like, like, just have some like tea, right?
Yeah, yeah, have some time.
Yeah.
Like, the only meme I know is a what?
where they reanimated some i think it was like like like
some cantonese movie into a beaver like that's the only like
meme i know you know that one wait what is you don't know
the beaver the beaver video meme like somebody it was like
some super passionate speech in cantonese and then they like
reanimated it into a beaver like the dramatic beaver yeah
Wait, you know what?
You never heard of that one?
Send it to me.
Wait, okay.
I think it's because, like, it got so...
Like, was it in Cantonese or Mandarin?
I don't remember.
But, like, I just remember it got, like, so...
Oh, it wasn't Cantonese?
Sorry.
Grat, Auntie Doki's memory's not as good as it used to be.
Wait, then, what was it in?
It's because like okay, it's because like it was that meme
got so popular apparently that it it Transcended overseas so
like people overseas were like what is this?
I was really they couldn't understand what he was saying But
like wait this is pretty funny, but they didn't understand
what the beaver was saying So that's what I knew about it
just because like it went overseas Well, I'll show you I
kind of want to okay.
Yeah, I'm still interested.
Let me see if I can find
Okay.
Oh, yeah, see, it's one of the original Cantonese.
I knew it.
It's a better tomorrow.
Yeah, it was in Cantonese.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, I knew it because, like, I could understand most
of what they were saying.
It was this one.
I've never seen this in my home.
see why is he have like a wound on his it was like
reanimated from the actual movie it was like his persona or
something like yeah it got it has 2.3 million views because
people people like overseas were like what is this people
Wait, is this fun?
I don't know what he's saying, but this is so funny.
Yeah, there's like subtitles, so I can kind of get it.
Yeah, so it's like, it's based off...
Wait, I'll show you the original clip.
This is based off...
This is the original clip.
I've never seen this yet.
You've never seen this one?
No, I've never seen this.
Maybe it was, like, not that popular, like, in, like, the
Chinese internet culture.
I...
I was never...
You know, I didn't know Chinese for, like, a long time.
Yeah, but this was three months ago Yeah, this is Never seen
it I Maybe it's just because like This is not a grandma meme
I don't know like I've never seen this Guys, this is not a
grandma meme.
It's literally three months ago.
I This is from a 1986 movie.
That's a meme was three months ago It's not ancient.
You sure?
It's not ancient.
The movie might be old, but the meme is young.
The meme is young.
Maybe the memes are made by all the aunties.
All the grandmas and grandpas.
Be naive.
No!
We should take your 1986 movie and put it as a meme.
I don't even know how to say young in Chinese I don't even
know how to say young in Chinese
I'm so scared like I'm like okay I pray to God I'm going I'm
saying the correct word because my pronunciation is crap
honestly I'm so scared.
It's not as bad as me.
Really?
Of course, yeah.
It's not as bad as me.
Because you actually can, you're actually practicing
speaking Chinese too on Billy Billy.
I'm not.
I'm so like my pronunciation has deteriorated a lot over the
years.
Because I'm mostly speaking English now.
Have you, have you ever learned like, you play Apex, I play
Apex, right?
Yeah.
Have you ever learned the like Apex characters?
Chinese names.
You've like taught me some of them.
I remember like you taught me like, what was it?
What was it, the charge rifle?
Zbong?
Yeah, zbong.
Yeah, yeah.
Like you taught me.
Yeah.
And I remember you taught me, like, you try to teach me the
other names and then I forgot.
The new character, like I was telling you, like I streamed
like 16 hours.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
The new character speaks Cantonese.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I, yeah.
Because like I didn't know that.
And then she suddenly she was like done done and i was like
i was like yeah she scared me i actually actually wait was
that cantonese i was like she's like done done and i was
like i was like wait i understood her he was like suddenly
aware and i was like oh my god wait i know what she's saying
yeah do you know actually actually do you know conduit
conduit's Chinese name is kind of like the first time I
learned it everyone was telling me it was a bad word by the
way in Chinese Really?
I don't know if you if you understand like like her I call
her Tao Guan Tao Guan Wait, what does that mean?
I don't know that word.
It's like apparently it okay.
It's apparently Like masturbation or something like that wow
that's our chinese name so i was like so when i first
yeah so when i first learned it i was like why is it a bad
word you know i was like
yeah yeah that's why i was like i was like when i'm learning
all like the legend names i'm like yeah why why is this guy
called this you know what i mean yeah yeah oh my god do you
know octane's no it's octane's nickname octane's nickname in
chinese is fight fight do you know what fight i don't know
that but the other one is like kid right yeah fight gay is
like white white to give it's like white flag you know it's
like he he's like oh he basically like just stims and dies
all the time.
So they call it like Bai Gay.
It's called Bai Gay in Chinese.
Bai Gay Xiaozi.
That's when he stims and dies.
Yeah.
That's what you name.
They just call him like...
Like feeder type deal.
Dong Li Xiaozi, actually.
Dong Li Xiaozi.
But then they call him Bai Gay Xiaozi now.
Yeah, yeah.
They're like...
Yeah.
They give like nicknames like you.
Yeah, he's evil with them.
Yeah, he's just...
he just goes and dies that's so good unfortunately it's such
a good name there is a caustic caustic yeah it's like
fireman it's i remember it yeah you remember yeah p-man what
p-nan oh yeah p-nan i like how that was the one i remember i
was like oh my god i remember this his name was the most
like fucked up i was like fart man yeah i really like to
like like learn your names it's it's really weird you know
it's like yeah it's like slang names like nicknames and
stuff that's so interesting i was like bloodhounds just dog
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah dog man yeah it's really literal
actually in chinese yeah yeah like i think like i remember
like i read something about like like the nicknames they
have for different things it's always like it's interesting
yeah it's it's like literal i think yeah it's very literal
too gosh i wish there's like there was like a popular like i
don't remember it was like a gamer show where they they were
like uh they were giving nicknames too but i always find it
very interesting like the type of nicknames that come up
like uh the chinese nicknames they come up with because it's
sometimes is like really fucking funny yeah yeah yeah I I
really like it like I watch a little bit of like the talk
show and all that sometimes just to learn and yeah I really
like it as well it's funny I miss I miss have you I miss
watching like like um like Chinese like variety shows
because there's like some really funny ones like when I grew
when I was growing up okay when I if i didn't watch anything
oh true true wait but have you ever heard i always talk
about this one to my chat but you ever heard about the one
where like um it's like a bunch of women like with buttons
and stuff and then one guy comes out and like he has to like
talk about like his life and like why he is like the perfect
uh he can be like the perfect boyfriend slash husband and
then like he gets judged by like a panel of women and like
and then like there'll be like videos playing about his life
and then one by one women will like press the button as like
no he's not the perfect guy for me like rejected him we
never thought that show was so popular i don't know if it's
still like it still goes does the stat show still goes on
yeah yeah it was a dating show but it was like so popular it
was like really popular back then i don't know if it still
is like dating wow i haven't watched like a dating show yeah
but it's like some okay okay to be like a show that like
parents love to watch and then I would watch it with them it
was like the parent show like every parent like every parent
would watch it really yeah no it's true bro my dad was like
oh my god my mom watches that show all the time and it was
true See, my dad loved that show I think you're exposing
your teeth I didn't watch it willingly It was on TV Okay, I
did watch it willingly Because I did I could choose not to
watch it with my parents But it was interesting It was funny
Because sometimes it was like Sometimes it was like The guy
would be like Really not a good person Really?
Like he'll be like like an extra deadbeat But he'll be on
the show And then like, you just see like a panel of women
Just be like pressing the button Because he would show
videos of his life And there would be a one moment Where all
the women would just be like No and then he just pressed the
button And they'd be like Pomp, pom, pom, pom, pom Like all
of them rejecting it
But what is the show called, guys?
It was so popular.
the host was a bald man yes i remember his the host he's so
famous he's like super fucking rich now because that show
made him like really famous because he was such a good host
can you not read it somebody wrote it i don't know what does
that say you know in my chat i can't read it i told i can't
read i can't read i can't really wait
Wait, I've never heard of that in my life.
I've never heard of that.
You've never heard of that show?
It's famous.
Wait, what kind of Chinese shows do you know?
That's not old.
I don't know.
I don't know Chinese shows that are...
Like, doesn't your, like...
Doesn't your chat recommend you some shows to watch?
Mostly, it's not really...
How do I put it?
Like, it's mostly, like, the Sanko or COG type that they
recommend.
Like, the really old one, which everybody knows.
Wait, you can't call me old.
Your chat recommends these things to you.
Like, okay, they're recommending me, like, classic,
classical stuff, you know?
Yeah, and I'm like...
I watch the classical stuff.
Because I'm cultured.
You watch classical and, like...
In what and what?
We didn't recommend you any like newer.
Going to VIP theater.
Okay, look.
It's classy.
Wait, what kind of shows that your chat recommends you?
Honestly, they don't recommend me.
need some but like I don't really look for them for like
recommendations or shows wait you don't because it's more
you don't trust your chat I uh it's because I mostly watch
the ones that they already recommend me and only it's only
the classical ones because they don't really watch TV shows
you know wait what do they watch they only watch people
nowadays they They watch, you know, they watch movies still,
but like most people just look at videos all the time.
Oh, like, oh, because like, oh, so it's just like, like,
it's just like N.A.
Where, like, people don't watch, like, shows anymore.
They just watch, like, like, streamers and, like, YouTube
videos.
Do you think VTuber, like, I mean, honestly, like, they
watch more anime, I think.
Well, there's like, there's like, Chinese animation is
really good, good now, too, I heard.
Yeah, okay, there are really good Chinese, like, some really
good Chinese girly animations, but mostly everyone still
watches like Japanese animations.
Like, Bidi Bidi is actually, like, do you know, like Bidi
Bidi was like, uh, uh, vocal like Miku, Miku fans fan, like,
like, like everyone is like, it was called Miku fans or
something.
Oh, Miku.
Oh, I mean, Volko has always been like super crazy popular
worldwide.
No, but it's like, it's like an Otaku, basically, like,
Like, like, yeah, everyone there is like anime fan.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
What's...
So, so they mostly watch into anime stuff.
But there are still a lot of people that watch like TVs,
talk shows and all those things.
It's just that they don't really recommend it to me since
like I don't think I've watched that many as well.
Oh, so they're just saying you might not like like.
as much as they do.
Or it is like the way they're talking.
And then like speaking wise might be like a bit calm.
Yeah, it's like it's like really it's because they talk
really fast.
Because they're like it's like fluent.
So it's like maybe harder to understand type deal.
That's true.
I did not understand what was going on in that dating show.
But like from what I could like piece out from the words I
do understand.
It seemed really funny.
Yeah.
yeah talk shows are just too too fast like they talk
extremely fast like back and forth kind of thing it's really
difficult but like i try sometimes yeah yeah that makes
sense yeah do you know like what is like uh basically otaku
in chinese wait what is otaku in chinese erciyan erciyan
erciyan yeah it's like it's like like how How do I put it?
Like, there is China.
China is like, China is Chinese.
But that's mostly like...
I would say Erchiyen is more accurate.
What does that mean?
Erchiyen.
You don't know Japanese.
Erchiyen is two, right?
Er...
And what's...
Erchiyen?
I only know it in Japanese.
Wait, I'm trying to translate it in English.
in my brain it's not working oh 2d yeah it's like two it's
like like like like like yeah 2d oh i don't know if you know
that 2d 2d is the best it's true yeah yeah because we're 2d
and we're pretty cool are you actually are you pretty young
not an auntie yeah donkey do you are you like into you're a
vtuber but do you are you at ursa yet okay to be fair i'm
like okay i always tell my chat this but i'm actually like
really normy like like i'm actually very normy um because
like i like i actually watch 3d shows like you know flesh
flesh shows okay people that are like flesh and not 2D.
I actually don't watch a lot of anime, to be fair.
But it's only because, yeah, but it's only because like, um,
because like I like to, I like to watch subs, not dubs.
So like, I watch, so like, I have to read it.
And I don't have the time to like, just sit down and watch
anime type deal.
Like, I, if I'm watching a show, I always do something in
the background while I'm watching something so like so i can
like split my attention like i can just like if i i don't
have to look at the screen all the time i can just like
listen to what they're saying and also like you know do
stuff so like i think like i other than like i think i'm
trying to think of like the last anime i've watched oh my
god don't don't tell me like a 1980 anime i do watch the new
stuff but it's like only if it's like super like like you
know it's like the most popular thing on the internet type I
tried to watch like two episodes of Oshinoko and then I
stopped after two episodes because I got depressed Oh yeah
actually Oshinoko I actually also like I watched I spoiled
myself a bit and I was I was like okay okay I can't read
it's really it's kind of sad it's too real
so like I stopped and then like I think that was like the
last anime i've watched but like i would watch like you know
like oh my hero academia was so popular like i mean i guess
it's so popular but i would watch i think i watched like the
first season of my hero academia when it first came out and
then and then like oh like like uh demon slayer was so
popular so i watched the first season of demon slayer when
it came out and then like oh jjk is currently so popular so
i watched the first season mainstream i like Extremely
mainstream.
It's like, all the things you're listening is that, hmm,
okay.
Yeah, I told you I'm normie.
I just watched the mainstream.
I told you.
I don't watch.
I just watched the mainstream stuff.
The only time I've, like, gone out to watch, like, things
that weren't mainstream or, like, red stuff that weren't
mainstream.
It was, I was, like, years ago, I feel like.
but like some of my favorite like i don't know if you ever
heard of the liar game that's like one of my favorite like
non-mainstream i heard of yeah i i probably have it's
basically because like death note is like one of my favorite
like manga slash anime of all time like i love okay death
note is nice it's okay wouldn't you mean nice the way you
yeah it's nice you know what i give you a point for that i'm
like in my head i was like Okay, I gotta, I gotta like count
everything, everything that she said so far.
It's like, it is like a work of art.
But I honestly, I love like everything.
Like I love the writer and the illustrator, like when they
work together.
Like I love everything they do together.
So like I've read like almost everything they've done, like
after Death Note.
Like Baku Man, I love Baku Man.
I don't know if you heard of Baku Man.
it's like yeah yeah i have i have yeah it's but like yeah
i'm like and then like yeah it's the one where like they it
was like basically like parodying like shonen jump and like
like what it's like to be a manga writer and illustrator so
like i watched i like i love um i love bakuman and i love
defno but like yeah defno was like my favorite all-time
favorite i think it was like like before defno i didn't
really care about anime and manga like i was like super
normie where i didn't even care other than like the shows
that like my parents grew up with because like my parents
grew up with like Dr. Slump and like IQ IQ Bossier, Dr.
Slump, okay IQ Bossier and then like oh my god and then Shin
Chan you know Shin Chan right?
Shin Chan's so fucking fun yeah yeah yeah I'm like listening
to you list off the anime I know it's old and older I know
it's old My parents grew up with it So like They like you
know how like they grew up with it So they had the DVDs and
the manga And then so they gave it to me to watch And they
gave it to me to watch So I watched it growing up So like
And then there's like oh yeah Chibi Maruko-chan Oh my god
that's so old That's actually old old I actually didn't
watch chibi i think chibi marco i watch yeah chibi marco i
think it's because the opening too
you're really opening that was fire i was too young to
remember okay it's a good opening
it's a good opening
No, there's like, okay, wait, no, there was like a
Peely-pada Peely-pada-pada-pada Yeah, that part, it was just
so catchy.
Yeah, that one is like...
I think even now, like, a lot of people still know it.
Exactly!
It doesn't mean I'm old!
That's the only part, though.
Peely-pada, Peely-pada-pada-pada-pada-pada-pada.
It's a good opening!
Yeah, Su-yinti.
That's what it's called Tsuyinji Because I only knew like
the name I knew the name In in Cantonese But I didn't know
the name I forgot the name in like Like Japanese Um And then
But your Cantonese Then your Cantonese Is really great right
now Like Like it's better than your Chinese Like Um I would
say so Cause like Um Because like I speak Cantonese at home
I don't speak Mandarin I don't speak like Chinese Mandarin
Um Because like Only my dad Knows how to speak Uh Mandarin
Um um but then like uh he like refused to teach me Mandarin
when I was growing up because he was like you don't need to
know Mandarin you just need to know Cantonese like because
he was like he's like why should we teach her to she's gonna
get confused because he was like she's just gonna get
confused if we teach her more than one so we'll just like so
we'll just speak in Cantonese and so I never I don't I only
only when I uh started getting older and like and when I um
moved overseas that like I started to learn like manner in
because like people around me were speaking manner in I'm
like why didn't you teach me manner in dad I was just like
why everybody's speaking Mandarin, why did you not teach me?
It's like all my extended family on my dad's side speaks
Mandarin and then they'll like tell me stuff and I'll be
like uh uh maybe they did try when you're like really young.
Oh yeah, and then I couldn't yeah, I couldn't like absorb
it.
Like we give up.
Like
They're like, oh no, she's too stupid.
We'll just go with one.
But your accent, your accent, like, for, like, like, like,
speaking Mandarin and Cantonese, like, Chinese and Cantonese
now is, like, pretty good, isn't it?
Like, because I'm, no, I feel like it's, it's worse because,
like, I don't use it as often anymore.
Like, I think you're, you're, you're definitely better
because you speak it more fluently than me.
like embarrassed sometimes because it's like you know I'm
really scared it's like the koin is like always there you
know koin yeah cool wait what's koin the accent is always
it's always there yeah you're maybe didn't like grow up I
think you didn't like naturally like grow up with the
surrounding you English and Japanese so it's like like when
I was learning Chinese and all that is really difficult
actually it's really difficult yeah right now like when i'm
speaking like like when when i see timbudong i'm like oh no
oh no did i just say that really badly or something that i
sometimes i'm scared too because i'm like oh no whatever i
pronounce something wrong ever since ever since in high
school when my friends laughed at me for speaking cantonese
i oh yeah trauma real trauma real trauma i look at people
which i'm like oh my god she finally spoke chinese and i try
to speak chinese should we should we speak all right okay
okay yeah yeah it it only took an hour and 30 minutes let's
try yeah
That's like a little kid.
Oh, I'm a little kid.
I'm...
Wait a minute.
You...
If you're...
If you're the...
You're the...
Pair...
Pair a little bit more.
You can do it.
Okay.
i'm like i'm like i want to like show you like like i want
to i want to teach you some really funny like a meme I think
but it's like it's like really difficult do you know like
there's like Chinese memes but it's very difficult to
understand like there's like a difference between like I
think English type of memes versus like the China Chinese
type of memes like what like they have they have like
abstract kind of memes like do you know there's like
something about do you know there's a place in China called
Guangdong yeah yeah i've been there that's where they speak
a lot of kentany yeah yeah and like and like apparently
there's a lot of cockroaches over there or something like
that yeah so i just recently learned this too i was like
wait what there's like a lot of cockroaches there and there
is like a meme where they they say like it's like it's like
because there's so many cockroaches there they like they
have a meme like saying the the guantung kangang it's like
the guantung cockroach is And they have like a picture of
the cockroach at a window.
It's like, it's really stupid.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Wait, do you have a picture of that?
Or is it just like a verbal thing?
I think I do.
But I need to find it.
It's like, it's like, there's a really, it's a really weird
picture.
It's just a cockroach looking.
Looking at a window, basically.
It's like, what do I say?
I guess I was like, I remember the giant cockroach.
is oh my god i remember too oh my god i remember like oh my
god this is like in because like in shinjin samzan i used to
live in uh samjan or shenzhen um and like uh and like i
remember like i told a story before a long time ago but like
i was just like i was getting ready for school and then like
i was about to leave and i felt something hit my head i was
like what and i shook my head and then i looked down and i
saw a fucking giant cockroach like between my feet and then
i freaked out and i like screamed i went back home like i i
was just like at the bout like you know like the bout before
you know like how in like actually i don't know what you
know but like actually like in like Chinese homes there's
like two layers so there's like you go out but it's not
outside yet like it's not outside your home yet so it's like
it's not backyard because it's like an apartment villa thing
so like you go out but it's like there's a balcony and you
have to go out again so like so I went out and then and then
not the set I didn't go out I went out and then and I ran
back inside and then like I took a shower and everything I
was late for school but like I couldn't I was like it
touched me yeah I'm are you scared of cockroaches oh I'm
scared of every type of bug I'm scared of every type of bug
I got slapped by a giant moth at one point when I was
walking down oh my gosh where was this place it was like I
remember like one time I took a school trip to oh my gosh
I'm trying to remember like where that place is in China but
like we were walking down this, me and my friends were just
like walking down this like pathway and a giant fucking moth
just slapped me in the face I was just like I was so unlucky
I'm scared of like sea lizards lizards?
Wait why are you scared of lizards?
I think it's PTSD wait wait what's the PTSD PTSD It's like,
so there's a time when I was younger and I stay alone, like
when I was a little kid already, like I had my own room,
basically.
My parents would be like staying in another room.
And it was dark, you know, in the room.
I was trying to turn on the light, basically, but I was kind
of small and short.
So I was like reaching for a really high light switch.
And like, when I turn it on, I felt something like drop on
my arm in the dark.
And I was like...
And I was like, what the hell is that?
You know kind of thing?
And I turned on the light.
I saw like a lizard on my hand.
And I was like, I freaked out.
And I screamed.
And I threw it on my bed.
And then like, and then like I disappeared under my covers
or something.
And I was like, I stood there.
I was like, oh crap.
Oh my God.
There's a lizard in my bed.
Because I was like a little kid.
I was like six or something.
Seven maybe.
oh my god it's so scary I was like I was like I was like oh
no there's like a lizard in my bed what do I do I can't
sleep here anymore and and like I cried because I was so
scared like I was because it was like on my bed and on my
hand and I just froze it I cried yeah and I cried and called
for my parents but the thing is like my parents were
watching like TV or something yeah and they thought that I
was laughing instead of crying yeah so I was like crying
calling for like my mom and then like she was like oh why is
she laughing so hard oh my god they thought i was laughing
so i stood there crying and i was like why aren't my parents
coming i'm like i'm like i'm crying here and and then like
then they call for me they're like what's so funny you know
like i'm not laughing i'm crying and then like i i didn't
sleep in bed for like two weeks oh my god no i've had like
two weeks i've had that moment before where like i think
like it was like i don't know i think i i think it was like
like it's like it was like i've had these moments where like
if i see like a bug at what in one in a room i just never go
back to that room like for like for like one to two weeks i
just never go back to that room like i remember like when i
was younger i think i saw like a spider or something in the
bathroom And then for one to two weeks, I just used my
parents' bathroom.
Because I was like, I'm not going.
I was like, what if it comes back?
Like spiders, being a spider, like I've been like, I don't
know why.
But like, okay, so currently, I stream in like a separate
room from my sleeping.
Like, my bed is in another room, right?
Yeah, I have like 3D camera set up, actually.
I have like home 3D setup in the other, like, stream.
yeah and like there's a spider in here somewhere actually
and like it only comes out when I play Apex and I have no
idea why yeah yeah it has disturbed me like I think four
times so far when I'm streaming as well only when I'm
streaming by the way and like um like during other times
when I'm streaming other things like it does not even bother
me at all but like when I'm when I'm playing apex i'm like
fighting a team and it it'll suddenly come in front of me
like it'll hang in front of me or it'll drop on my lap and
i'm like oh crap there's a spider and i have to like afk you
know and like sometimes i'm like i'm like dead 30 i'm like
basically a death box oh my god it just like it only comes
yeah i had no idea why the spider just enjoys the gameplay
you say no watch you play It's been, like, bothering me.
I even have, like, a spray now because it's...
Wait, is it going crazy?
Yeah!
I don't know.
Maybe it had, like, a wife.
Like, yeah.
Wait, no, don't say that because then there could be
multiple spiders now.
That's scary.
Oh, no.
Oh, sorry.
There was, actually.
Wait, speaking of which, there was...
Trauma.
Recently, recently.
It was, like, my most recent spider encounter.
There's two.
There was two of them.
I remember.
And I was freaking out because there's two of them.
by the way i was like why are there two of them oh yeah i
was scared but oh well oh no why is there two of them it's
okay i'm not scared of bugs it's okay i'm not that i think
like spiders i think it's okay if there's two of them then
that means it might be two females or two males because like
i think like the female eats the male spider if they're
after so like if if you find out there's one spider left
then maybe you should get worried yeah just maybe after
there's one spider left that means it ate it ate the male
spider yeah well i'm but you're scared of bugs right i'm i'm
okay actually like i'm i'm pretty okay with bugs it's just
if they are on me then i kind of like on me you know what i
mean oh yeah that's why you get the mosquito net yeah yeah
if it gets really bad i remember i used to sleep with the
mosquito net when i was younger i would have like like you
know like the the nets that would go over your bed and stuff
yeah i only use it once i think i really when i was growing
up in asia i used it a lot because i my blood was apparently
really delicious so then i would get like bit very often
yeah so like it's like like for those who don't know chat
like mosquitoes only target you if you have really delicious
blood it's like a particular blood type i don't know what
blood type i am because like i never found out maybe i don't
know maybe there's a record somewhere like yeah i don't know
what my blood type is but um so like you get bit a lot it's
because your blood type is like um a particular blood type
that mosquitoes really really like and so like i had to like
i had like mosquito nets and then i would wear these
bracelets that was like mosquito repellent bracelets and
stuff um and then i would like have to spray my subway
repellent every fucking day uh because if i don't i scratch
a lot yeah i couldn't help myself i would scratch myself a
lot i think i'm pretty similar if i'm not mistaken well i
don't think they bite me that much but they used to bite me
as well i used to have mosquito repellent as well like i'm
but i'm like oh I'm like, oh, I don't remember it's O.
It's the one that can give blood to everyone.
The O that gives blood to everyone.
Yeah, blood type O is universal.
Yeah.
But there's like O minus O.
I would like, I think like...
I don't know which one it is.
I know like my dad's blood is even more delicious than mine.
So then like, I remember like when we go on trips, like we
would just stick with my dad.
So then all the mosquitoes will bite my dad instead of me.
That was like, you get like a meat shield.
will target one person and
even as a kid it's true my mom taught me that I was like
stick with dad his blood is more delicious it wasn't my idea
your mom is yeah Yeah, she thought you well.
Doesn't she watch your stream?
Yes, she does.
It's actually so cute, like, family watching streams.
Yeah, so do you want to say some curse words?
Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I actually didn't expect...
Like, I was excited.
so scared that we're gonna speak like full Chinese entire
time.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Oh my god.
Bro, okay.
Somebody my chat was like, the worst part was when they fly
around your ears.
Oh, I hate that.
I hate that so much when the mosquitoes fly around your ear.
Oh my god.
I could never sleep.
If I hear a mosquito, I just don't sleep.
Really?
Yeah.
You know, when the mosquitoes fly and it's like and it's
like so high pitched too.
It's like, and then I get super paranoid too because I was
like, oh no, he wants my blood or she wants my blood.
It's like probably like, I can't sleep until she's dead.
Oh yeah.
I rarely hear, actually I think my room, like I keep like a
can, like basically like bug spray nearby in case.
Yeah, I do have one.
So I regularly make sure it's like, yeah.
I like, I would like have like I have like, I think like
later on because it got really bad so i had to get the
mosquito zapper you know the blue light the blue light and i
would just sleep with the blue light on and it would be like
oh god yeah i think i bought a racket once i think we oh no
i i'm too fucking scared to use a racket because it's like
too close because you know there's like like and then like
you know like the fly wing like the mosquito wings come off
because you're zapping in and i'm like oh i don't want it
near me so i just have like i just I bought the mosquito
zapper, like, and I put it on the ground, and it'll be like,
pop, pop, pop, like, I think, like, the scariest shit is,
like, you know, like, when you open the window, you have the
mosquito, mosquito, um, screen, you know, like, the screen
that you push out, so, like, you don't let the mosquitoes
in, but you can have, like, outside air come in, and then
you just see, like, the mosquitoes just fucking be like, let
me in.
That's just, I'd never open the window.
Like, I would never open the window because I just see,
like, all the mosquitoes outside being, like, let us in.
Like, maybe it's where, like, the area you lived in had,
like, a lot of mosquitoes.
Oh, no, no, I lived.
I lived in an area.
I remember, like, growing up, I would always, we were always
living areas with a lot of trees and, like, grass and
everything.
So, so, so I would always do, I would see the mosquitoes
outside and be like, let us in.
Oh, yeah.
Like, the area I live in, like, they did, they did, like,
regular fogging, basically.
Like, kill.
Yeah, because, you know, it's pretty disgusting, like, like,
all the mosquitoes.
So they do, like, fogging all the time.
Oh, I'm very, I didn't need to use any nets, like.
my god i only use it like once ever that's so nice
everywhere i lived like when i lived in asia because i moved
around a lot everywhere i lived there was so many mosquitoes
because there was so much nature around us well it's not
even nature it was like like sometimes like i would live in
like um like a mini gated community because i would at one
point i lived with my grandparents and They lived in a Like
a gated community And then like But like Every It was like
You know There's like a park And then there's like Trees
around us And everything So there was a lot Of mosquitoes
And then it was Cicadas too So I could hear Them go like Oh
Oh that's so annoying Yeah it was so Every morning You know
Like I had Okay it was in the wall Somewhere What It was in
the Like how did it get there Like I think it went Through
like a pipe Or something Like I don't know But like it was
it was so noisy like i was so i on bitty bitty they have
like an app for your phone yeah and you can do phone stream
by the way like like it's like i think youtube you can do
phone yeah yeah you can yeah you can you can use your i can
use my live 2d in that app basically it's like it's like
like like a customized app or something and um i was trying
to do a phone stream like in my room like just with live 2d
and like my like basically everybody could hear the cicada
going like yeah yeah it was really loud like at night i
couldn't sleep by the way it was so noisy like it was just
constantly uh making noise at night and it was so difficult
to sleep actually oh my god so close as well it was like
right above my bed like somewhere you know in those pipes so
yeah yeah oh my god yeah what is he doing how did he survive
for so long aren't you so long i swear i was like looking
out when do cicadas die right like what is your lifespan
yeah i was like i was i was wondering because i was like
this guy has been here for so long and it's i was like
losing sleep over it so i was like i was going crazy i was
like please just just die like like i can't take it already
apparently five weeks how long did it live for Well, a while
until like...
Until...
Yeah, I was like hitting my wall because occasionally if I
slam my door hard enough, it would like shut up for a bit.
Yeah, it was like...
What's that?
Yeah!
Well, I had to...
So I had to like slam my door like when I'm going out of my
room, I'll just close it really hard.
And it'll like shut up for like 10 minutes, 15 minutes.
And then I'll be like, ah, peace and quiet.
Yeah.
Oh my god, that's thinking it was just like, hey, that's
this is who's who's invading my home Who's this who's this
girl?
What is she doing in my home making all that noise?
I'm trying to find a mate right now.
The worst part is that it got used to it, you know, it
actually got used to my door slamming At one point I was
trying my best to slam the door.
I slammed it like three times in a row and it still kept
going It's not phased anymore.
He just thinks like, he just thinks it's just nature.
He's like, oh, it must be like, it must be like some nature
thing in my new place that I'm living in.
Yeah, that was really bad.
I was like, oh God, I'm going crazy with this decade.
I gotta like sleep in my streaming room for a bit or
something.
Oh no, that's terrible.
Oh my God.
That sucks.
just like thinking how did it get in your walls like i don't
know i have no idea actually i actually not sure how it how
the hell it got like in a pipe or something because you know
how cicadas you know how cicadas like like they they only
come up like after like a couple of decades right you know
that right well i no not really actually okay so you know
why i've never had a cicada like near my home before i've
never i've never that was like my first time ever and i was
like why is there why is there a cicada in my walk okay i
never heard this back okay so like if you don't like cicadas
are actually like they live underground for like um they lay
dormant for a long time and then like after like seven oh
yeah after like 17 years they come out and would be like
they'd Like, yeah, I don't know If that's like Asia, I don't
know if that's Asia's cicadas, but I know, like Is this the
same as Asia's cicadas?
I am not actually that sure, but I know Like, because like
in NA, it was a problem Because like, there was a problem I
only know that because like In NA Oh, I think I heard about
it Yeah, yeah, so like because it comes out in NA They come
out after 17 years So like in NA they actually have like a
like a calendar to let people know when the cicadas come out
um and then like um so that at one point there was two
cicadas that were gonna come out at the same day like on the
same day which was crazy because like it was gonna be a huge
problem because there's so many of them like some news about
that yeah the news were freaking out yeah yeah because like
Like, in NA, we had the 17 years once, and people were like,
oh, no, there's gonna be so many cicadas.
It looked like an invasion.
Yeah, there was gonna be an invasion.
It was similar to, like, the killer bees.
Yeah.
It was similar, like, because I don't know why, but for some
reason, we have, like, NA has, like, some fucked up thing
with bugs, because we also had, like, the killer bees at one
point, where there was, like, an infestation of bees that
are, like, the killer wasp.
the killer wasp there was an infestation of killer wasp that
play wasp i'm scared of wasp me too i'm freaking scared of
wasp as well and yeah there was like like a killer wasp
epidemic or something and then like and then people there
was on the news and stuff were like oh no the killer wasp
we're moving to like this area now oh my god be careful
everybody it was a problem yeah yeah it It was a problem.
It's so scary, honestly.
I'm scared.
It's like, I'm not usually that scared of bugs, but like, if
it's like in large numbers or if it's like, okay, deadly or
something like that, like it'll hurt me, then of course I'm
pretty scared.
Like, okay, no.
Oh yeah.
100%.
Yeah, I'm, that's why this is why I have an immense fear of
insects.
I have such a fear.
I just, I was just, I don't care how small they are.
It's just, oh, they just, they look weird.
They look funky too It's be like what about butterflies and
I'm like like have you ever seen a close-up picture of a
butterfly?
It's hideous Aren't it cute?
Huh?
No Look up a close-up photo of a butterfly.
Really?
No, they're fucking disgusting No
Isn't it cute?
mean look it's pretty cute okay your definition of cute is
now i'm judging you it's pretty it's what you mean look at
the eyes what the what do you mean there's millions of
little dots in their eyes what okay the only bug i will say
is cute is the domesticated moth How do you see Like have it
The fluffy ones Are pretty Okay I only think the
domesticated moths Are are cute It's because they're also
like Extra fluffy But like I told my chat this But
domesticated moths Are We domesticated them So hard That
like Their main purpose Is when they come out of their
cocoons Is to bang Lay eggs And then die five days later
That's their lifespan And because like they can fly because
we domesticated them so like they cannot fly at all So like
their wings are just decorations and then their mouths don't
work.
They're just decorations They can't eat at all so like
that's so sad.
Yeah, it's it's like so fucked up, but that means it could
never fly on me So like I think like insects that can fly is
the most fucked up thing ever Because like, I just don't
want them to fly at me.
And like, so basically, they can't...
Their mouths, they can't use it to eat or anything.
It's just like decoration.
So they don't have like...
It doesn't work.
I don't think...
It's like they don't have...
Well, at least they get to get, you know...
They get to bang before...
Before...
The thing is, I told my chat this.
But like, the mobs...
Like, the male mobs don't know...
They don't know how to stop.
So, like, they'll be like...
stuck to the female moths and you have to like pry them your
out yourselves because like they don't know how to pull out
so like so like the owners have to like have to like like
like pull them out by themselves like the the breeders and
then because then if they if the male moths don't the female
mouse can't lay eggs so like they would like be stuck
together until they die oh my god
i learned something they would yeah because they're like
because of like the like people have like humans have to
intervene or the they'll like they'll be stuck together
until they fucking die and the female moss won't be able to
lay eggs so then well wow but yeah and then they starve to
death because they can't eat yeah that's pretty sad but well
that's their whole purpose I think that's like a lot of
insects whole purpose it's just a it's just a bang and then
I mean like I told a story before but like There's a species
of mice that also does it.
The male mice bang so much that they just get a heart attack
and die.
Wait, how much?
Like, a lot to the point where they get a heart attack.
Wait, how much do you have to do that to get a heart attack?
I'm so few.
I think this is a research you have to do yourself.
I don't want to have that search history of like...
There's too much cardio, you know?
Yeah, like, I learned that in National Geographic about the
mice.
I think it was like, I think it was like, I don't remember.
Like, for some reason, that memory, that fact, the mouse
fact is so, like, ingrained in my head because, like, it's
so ingrained in your head.
Okay, it's like, okay, it's really fucked up.
Okay, because like I was watch, I was like in my
grandparents room and I was like watching TV in my
grandparents room and I was like watching National
Geographic and I rarely ever get a chance to be in my
grandparents room and in like that one moment I get to be in
my grandparents room and I was just by myself in my in the
room and I was just watching National Geographic and that
rat, the rat mouse fact just stayed in my head for the
longest time because I was like the one of those rare
moments I get to be in my grandparents room.
It didn't so happen.
It was about that I don't remember anything.
I don't remember anything else from that show.
I just remember the mouse thing because I was just like It
feels so interesting.
It was so interesting.
Oh my god.
My mod found the species the type of rat.
Really?
I think it is that rat.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They found it.
They're like The mouse experienced mass mortality after
mating.
with male survival only observed in the very rare cases when
they actually found the rat species holy shit that's crazy
wow i never knew that i'm learning i'm learning so much
until they get a heart attack i know you're like you're like
should we oh wait wait here's a He's a He's an animal fact
For in In China No not in Chinese Remember that bear You
remember that That bear that looked like a human Wait Huh?
The sun bear Oh You know sun bears I know I've seen it I've
seen a picture of Yeah Remember that Yeah A guy Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah Remember the fucking People were like Is that a
person I remember when it went viral He's seen I was like, I
also was like, wait, that's not a person.
Yeah, yeah, people were like, and then the zoo had to, like,
release the statement.
Yeah, the zoo had to release a statement.
I was like, please, stop calling our sunbears a human.
He's a real bear.
They hired a person to just be in the outfit.
Yeah, during the summer, like, that person would fucking
die.
Like, it's so fucking humid, it too.
Yeah.
But, but honestly, it does look like one.
It does, okay, but, yeah, true.
It does look like a human.
It doesn't look like a real bear.
But it's a very, it's, that sun bear has always never looked
like a real bear.
I remember I saw the video and I was like, holy shit, it
does look like a person.
I actually thought I was like, no way that could be a bear.
There's just somebody in the barrel.
He has a lot of skin.
It's like, I think this is my favorite picture of a sun
bear.
I'm gonna, don't worry guys.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
It looks like a fucking NPC.
Isn't it?
It looks like a game NPC.
Yeah, right.
Because I'm big now.
You're still gonna be resized.
God, I'm like looking at like the even even just randomly
googling it's so weird.
Okay, wait, let me show my chat the sun bear.
I'm looking back at sun bears too and I'm like, oh my god.
Like, like, yeah, I think I saw this image, I remember.
It was definitely this image.
And like I saw this, I was like, no.
Like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a person just waving.
Yeah, it is.
There you go, guys.
Here's a sun bear.
This is a real bear.
It's not a fucking 3D model, guys.
It's a real bear.
Look, you can tell it's a guy, too.
It's really goofy.
It's so, it's so fucking funny.
I love it.
I love how goofy they are.
just looks like a human and when i first saw it it was the
waving picture so i was like no no that can't be real yeah
it's just a person waving at the guy in a burst also the
mouth how it's always open oh it's just it looks like it's
just static you know yeah yeah i mean like why are you
scamming us it's a person they're like please please stop
saying our bear is a human being he's a real bear i love
okay i love like the red random like like animals animal
facts and like the red like especially like the pandas i
love like have you seen like videos of like oh of like yeah
i love actually pandas are so cute okay but they're like
really stupid though like like i was watching the video it's
like we have to like we have to literally like take care of
them or they'll like die we're literally making sure they
don't die out like because like without human intervention
like they cannot take care of themselves i'm pretty sure
he's like i was watching a video i someone's like but that
makes them more cute because they can't take care of
themselves the animals that are like a bit stupid are pretty
cute because like because like okay because like i remember
like there was like a video i was watching of like the uh
the the zookeepers uh trying to like uh take care like
trying to because like it takes a very long time for pandas
to um to it takes a very long time for pandas to like
reproduce like i think they reproduce like one like i don't
even know once a year or something not even once a year it's
like longer and but you have to force them to like because
they're never in the mood they're like like like because
like i remember that was watching a video that was a
documentary talking about pandas and like the scientists and
like the zookeepers trying to make them because like they're
endangered and then the problem was that they had to show
pandas videos of how other pandas being to like encourage
them to get in the mood this is how they do it it's not yeah
yeah and then um And then, but the thing, and then like, if
a female panda has twins, they would, they cannot process
that they have twins.
So they'll be like, no, I can only have one child.
So what a zookeeper does is that they would like, they
would, because like the baby pandas have to like still like
need the mom to like, like they still need the mom to like
take care of them.
So what they do is that they swap the baby pandas with each
other.
so like they'll be like all right daytime this will be the
daytime you get your mama nighttime we're swapping but then
the mama can't understand that they just think it's like the
one child they just think it's one kid and then it's so
funny because i was watching a video of how they do the
swaps and all they do is just give the panda like food
they'll be like here's food like and then like just take the
child and then the mama be like food and then they they just
grab the child out of the panda's hand and then like put
another child in his in her hand and she just doesn't notice
she doesn't care she doesn't know this or she doesn't care
yeah it's like yeah food w and like okay and like you know
how like they only eat bamboo right but like bamboo gives
zero and almost zero energy so they have to eat so much
bamboo to barely have energy every day because it gives like
zero fucking energy for a panda and that's why they're
mostly like sleeping because they have to save energy dude
it's actually oh my god it's just like i feel like i feel
like we're just making pandas work like worse as in like
we're making them lazier yeah
but they can't but the problem is like they just can't
survive already they can't yeah There's nothing we can do.
So there's nothing yet.
Yeah, there's nothing we can do.
We just don't want them to die out because they're so cute.
They're so cute.
Like, we have to.
We have to.
They're just too cute.
But oh my god, if we did not intervene, I feel like, I feel
like, like, I don't know.
I don't think they would be existing at this point if we
didn't intervene.
It's just, it's so funny.
Like watching, oh my gosh.
And then they're like, baby pandas are like, incredibly um
they're like incredibly clingy too yeah they like there was
a video i was watching with zookeeper just walking in and
then she had like three pandas three baby pandas just
holding on to her legs it's like don't go don't go yeah
they're so cute oh my god they're so cute they are but
they're so stupid
it's okay like i was saying like people people just like
stupid animals yeah they're just they're just like that's
what makes you know stupid in chinese wait uh you gotta keep
it chinese okay stupid wait wait uh uh wait i know this i
know this uh fuck uh it's in in the top of my head
no tc is crazy no that's crazy right yeah um wait what is it
wait what's stupid again it's it's the cute one the cute one
is like oh the cute one they say they say they call you like
shout like buntan oh yeah Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Chen, Chen is a Cantonese.
Chen.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Chen.
It's cute.
Yeah, but it's a cute way of saying it.
It's not really, they're like scolding you or anything.
Like, like, like really cursing you.
It's just calling you like a little bit stupid, you know?
Yeah, it's like, that's why like people like to watch me
because I'm cute and stupid.
And you too, right?
I'm basically like a panda!
Wait!
I'll die if you guys don't watch me I'm not stupid I'm just
like I literally have yeah I have like it's like 901 IQ by
the way in my description I'm extremely high IQ I'm just
like I'm just like a panda oh my god I need human
intervention I do not feed the panda chat guys I'm so hungry
do you want do you want to eat bamboo do you want to eat
bamboo it's
oh my god this is why people like to watch me I'm just like
a panda I'm cute but stupid yeah I'm cute but stupid can't
wait can't And shit Please intervene to keep me alive
I like how this was a try to speak Chinese stream And then
we're here I'm here giving like animal facts Hey, but it's
still I know You gave me like so many Yeah, but they're like
relevant Because like pandas are from China And like And
like that The mouse The mouse fact I talked about Are you
trying to like You're supposed to speak in Chinese.
Okay, but like, and also that mouse fact I told you guys
about, I learned it when I was like in China.
I learned that fact when I was in China watching in my
grandparents' room.
And also, the silk moths, the domesticated moths, they're
silk moths, which is relevant because like, silk is very
popular in Asia too.
So like, all my facts were very relevant to the topic.
okay um uh you know this thing is very relevant very very
relevant to this topic because because i'm saying that's why
that's why It's like, oh, relevant.
You can teach me Cantonese as well.
Oh, yeah, I can teach...
I know some curse words thanks to, like, people saying...
Yeah, I know Hamzap.
No!
Hamzap!
Yeah.
That's pervert.
I didn't know pervert.
I only know...
I only know a few curse who taught you pervert?
Did somebody call you?
My chat.
Your chat?
Wait, are they calling you?
They called you ham-sop?
No, they were like teaching me words and they were like,
hey, you should learn this word.
You should learn this word.
Wait, do you remember it in Chinese?
Wait, not in, what is this?
It sounds similar to the Japanese word.
Wait, what is it?
Hentai?
Yeah, it sounds similar to that.
Wait, wait, how do you say it?
The one I know is Bientai.
Oh, Bientai.
Wait, that's pervert?
Yeah.
So I can be like, I can be like, Nishi Bientai.
Can you say that?
Yeah.
Yeah, you can't.
Wait, you don't, but I'm not a pervert.
But you can.
I can say it, though.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's, it's, it, I was, when I was learning it, I was
like, wait, that's just, yeah, it sounds exactly like the
Japanese one.
Yay.
so easy.
Me and Ty has a negative connotation.
Well, it's pervert.
Pervert has a negative connotation in general.
It's not pervert.
Guys, there's no way you could make pervert a positive
connotation, guys.
Pervert is positive?
How can pervert be a positive connotation?
It's negative in general.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm trying to...
Is there a way?
No way.
No.
Not with that.
Can't be a good pervert.
No way you would be a good pervert.
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
You can't say it in like a cute way, I guess.
Like...
Bientai.
Wow, you said bientai, oh.
I mean, I mean, that's what...
Here, don't you know, like they play koi, like, you know,
the...
Like girls like you know how they are right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Even in Japanese it's like it's like
kind of Sundar type like I guess You're like You know like
Like that, you know like that, you know, it's like that You
know what I mean?
Why did you say brother?
Yeah, just looking same no it's like that my sister can't be
that cute
no yeah actually when i was learning it that confused me a
lot because like in chinese they always say like google and
jie jie for everything yeah every everybody call them google
and jie
yeah oh but recently there's another one you know i'll take
like they they like to say What does that mean?
Yeah.
Xiongdi is like, bro.
Oh, bro.
Xiondi, you how small.
Like, you smell so good.
Bro, what?
Wait, how do you use that in a context?
What's the context?
Context is he smells good.
Like, why would you use that?
Like, um, I guess, well, when you, when you're trying to,
when you're trying to joke with somebody, I guess.
Yeah, yeah.
yeah wait so you just go like bro you smell good wait how do
you say it again
yeah it's a popular like a meme now like at least in the
chinese yeah in the chinese community is i don't know why
they just like and then they sniff and they smell good
Xiongdi, you, doesn't it, Xiongdi?
No, Xiongdi.
What's the last one?
How do you say the last part?
Xiondi.
Xiong is like, it smells good.
You can use it as a fruit, too, by the way.
Xiong, Xiong, Xiong.
It just smells good.
Xiong, Xiong.
Oh my God, that's so...
Xiong.
Bro, bro, you smell good.
Yeah.
How Xiao is like, okay, that's a bit too much, you know?
Actually, there's, I don't know why, but there's like a lot
of like, like, weird, like, those kind of jokes, you know,
that they like to just randomly say, not really even in a
perverted way, it's just they, they like to joke around like
that.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, then there's another one.
Gijian.
Gijian?
What's Gijian?
Gijian.
He's like fencing.
Fencing?
What does that mean?
Just try and think of it in like a weird way.
In a weird way?
What do you mean by weird?
Fencing with something.
Wait.
Why do you know that word?
Because that's the thing they teach me.
What?
They teach...
What's the context?
Yeah, it's just fencing.
That's the context, you know?
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's like sword fighting.
It's also not even in a pervert.
Like, nobody really regards it as, like, a perverted
meaning.
It's just, it's just, like, a joke to them, you know what I
mean?
Oh, it's just like, bro, you want to...
Like a joke type here.
It's purely joke.
Girl, say it to me.
Yeah.
It's like 1v1 me, bro.
I feel like it's really bad when you translate it.
But like, it's like, it's really funny.
Like, just to hear it as like a joke, you know.
Oh, that's funny.
Wait, that's so funny.
Yeah, that's actually.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
How do you pronounce it again?
Yeah, it's literally fencing, by the way.
Xi Tian?
Is that?
G.
G .I .J.
A .N.
Yeah.
G.
Just gonna type it.
Bro.
G.
Okay.
Nobody says it like that.
No, no.
No.
Wait.
Fence me, bro.
That's what I'm trying to say.
You know what it says?
Just say fencing?
It is.
No, bro I don't think they add a wall Like, you know, like
me It's face me It's 1v1 me, bro Oh, I can't I'm in the
nation I'm trying to say 1v1 me, bro 1v1 Actually, you know
1v1 in like Chinese No, no, how do you say 1v1?
It's just Ida Ida I Like one hit one, you know?
It's like Idae.
I can't believe it.
I made it worse.
Yeah, you did make it worse, actually.
I was thinking, like...
This one's the worst part.
Like that meme, like the Shiondi, that one is like, they
usually use it with like Chikawa.
Do you know Chikawa?
Chikawa, no, what's that?
It's a very cute jacket.
Japanese animation, it like got like super popular basically
in their like community.
And like they, I don't know why some, some, some genius just
put like the text on top of like a really cute character.
And it's just so sad.
Wait, I'll show you a picture.
It's so sad.
Like, uh, what?
I'll copy this.
Okay.
sending it it's so cute oh wait oh I know yeah yeah yeah I
know that yeah yeah yeah I never know I never knew like the
name of it but I've always seen it ever it's so popular too
Chikawa yeah it's very cute if you've never watched Chikawa
it's very I've never watched Chikawa but like it's healing
I've like I've like I've seen it everywhere it's so popular
now it's like it's like the new Hamtaro it's like the modern
day Hamtaro.
Yeah.
Back in our day.
Or back.
I don't know about Hiro's day.
But back in my day.
We had Hamtaro.
I know Hamtaro.
Like a little bit.
I didn't watch it.
But like.
You never watched Hamtaro.
I remember.
Yeah.
But I remember like.
Like they had like toys of them.
And I was like.
When I was when I was a kid.
I remember.
When you buy like.
I think McDonald's maybe.
Yeah.
I like some drinks.
They'll.
give you toys right and like I remember there was like
Hamtaro toys and I was like what is this how could you say
that to Hamtaro Hamtaro walked so Chikawa can run
Hamtaro started the cute rodent fad when was Hamtaro Hamtaro
was so fucking old like Hamtaro if he was a real hamster
would be dead right now I mean Okay.
It's true.
It's old.
It must be really old.
It's like, apparently somebody said 90s.
Oh my god.
Is Hamtaro that old?
Okay, but it's like 90s in Japan.
So, like, by the time it came to NA, like, by the time it
came to NA, it was, like, a lot older.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
I am very sure it takes years to get.
It takes years.
to get shows to be like dubbed in english okay i only know
the english opening apparently like uh japanese opening for
hamtar is like really popular but i know the the english one
english opening that english opening oh i'm big again the
english opening for hamtar um wait let me see if i could
find it uh i didn't even know there is like english
um a lot of the shows like you know like how sailor moon
like like the the opening for sailor moon got like dubbed
into english as well like a lot of the openings back then
would get like dubbed into like english openings because
they're like and people are so stupid we need to dub
everything for them or they won't they won't watch it they
won't they won't watch it if the openings are not are not in
english I honestly I first I I was I still watch anime and I
watch some I I don't I don't watch dub at all yeah but like
when you're growing up like when you're growing up it's all
we had so like all the openings were we're uh and like the
openings didn't even like make sense sometimes like are like
different from the original opening so like have you ever
heard of the Digimon opening in English wait what no have
you wait okay because so like you know Digimon opening in
Japan is butterfly right I yeah I like yeah I love yeah
butterfly yeah but I grew up with the English Digimon
opening I never heard a butterfly before until like yeah it
was only until like um I think like in in high school when I
heard of the uh when I heard of Butterfly for the first
time.
I was like, what's this?
What the hell?
Wait, it's totally different.
What is this?
Digimon, Digital Monster.
Digital Monster's Champion.
What is Digimon?
Digimon, digital, this cut, this is all we had.
No!
I know you've never heard of the Digimon English opening.
No.
It was all we had.
Okay.
It was pretty catchy.
It was pretty good back then.
This is so interesting.
I've never seen this before.
I'm like just watching it.
I'm like, What is this?
It's just really different, you know?
Yeah, no, it is.
It's like so different.
And then we would have like, I mean, you know, like the
classic ones, the one with like, oh, wait, do you know
Yu-Gi-Oh?
Have you ever watched?
Wait, have you ever watched Yu-Gi-Oh?
Like, uh, like the Japanese opening of Yu-Gi-Oh?
I have, yeah.
Okay, I'll show you Yu-Gi-Oh ones.
Wait, there's Yu-Gi-Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yu-Gi-Oh!
opening English.
well it is like well there was no singing really they're
just like we gotta it's time to door it's always funny when
people because like I never heard of butterfly until high
school because like the Digimon movies like Digimon movies
were like uh becoming a thing and people were like digimon
movies and then i love digimon i love digimon i know like
digimon is like super popular uh in china too because like a
lot of like the merch i love digimon i love digimon because
like i bought a lot of like recently i bought a lot of like
digimon merch and it was all like collaboration like only
exclusive in like china too like you can order it online you
can order it online as well but like it was made for like
for in china and oh my god it's so cute too actually you
know surprisingly like china is like uh i feel like they're
like otaku and like animation oh they're figures really big
yeah it's really big it's like compare it's like almost like
comparable to like japan level you know like yeah yeah
they're cons the the conventions the the like that is so
true yeah they have like a whole like anime dedicated street
yeah yeah there's like I don't remember like I don't
remember what where I was but I remember like going to the
street and it was like you know like tailors and stuff
that's specifically there to make cosplay like oh yeah it's
just a cosplay street yeah yeah yeah yeah and there's like
and there's like all these like aunties and yeah all these
aunties and grannies there that would make like cosplay
items and I was like oh it was so it was so cute too because
like it's like all these like aunties and grannies like they
would have like these books and like what Kata Cosplay do
you want us to make you And then they would be like Making
cosplays and stuff For like cosplayers too Yeah that was so
cute Yeah all the owners are like I mean it's all like It's
all like older like people as well Yeah it's really cute
It's like it's actually really really cute It's so cute yeah
And it's like And it's so good quality too It's like I did
go like Shanghai I recently went in March right Yeah
Shanghai is extremely like like like anime culture is
extremely big there.
So like there's like collaboration cafes.
There's like there's a whole mall which is like anime like
like like just for Otaku.
There's like bitty merch as well there.
Like bitty anime merch.
Did you spot your own merch?
I saw my Nendo.
Oh, it's so cute.
That's really cute though.
You must be like that's me.
can't see it because you want to dox yourself so you're like
yeah i went like with my other friend like other vtuber
friend and we were like like whoa i can't say anything he
took pictures of everybody that i knew by the way like okay
i know this guy hey he was like i see you that's so cool
though it's really interesting yeah that's so cool my god
there's like Bucci, I remember when there was Bucci the
Rock.
Do you know Bucci the Rock?
Yeah, yeah, I know Bucci the Rock.
I didn't watch it, but I know it's super mainstream.
That's why I know it.
It's very nice.
Actually, I like Bucci.
It's quite a lot.
Bucci was pretty nice.
I only know it because of the meme, the face.
Like, when she, like, starts dying and then, like, the face
she makes, that's the only thing I know about Bucci the
Rock.
I heard that, like, the meme face that she makes.
The music's really nice.
I like the music a lot.
I haven't seen the show, because it's off like a rock band
it would be sad if it's like the rock band anime show and
then the music sucks like it's all okay okay yeah i think
currently there's like it was like everyone was like uh
raging over bochi and then there is like um my goal now i
think what what's that it's m-y-g-o i think it's uh what
dream you know bang dream no it's not normie enough for me
it's not it's Oh no!
Yeah.
So everyone loves it over in like the Chinese like
community.
They love that too.
I mean like, okay, so it's the music too, right?
The music's just really, really good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Music is like a big thing.
Oh, wait, it's a rhythm game?
Bang Dream?
I have figures of like Bang Dream, the girls.
Oh, I thought it was like an anime.
because you were talking about there is an anime but it's
like yeah it's like there's a rhythm game there's anime and
the anime just like came out like not too long ago like it
was like the like those rhythm games where you have to work
rows and stuff to play it it's like the the circle you know
yeah yeah yeah and then he was like the girl then the girl
you can call like the cards i think yeah yeah yeah like oh
my gosh it's so hardcore when i see people play rhythm games
Have you tried?
No, I'm so bad at rhythm.
I have zero rhythm.
But like, people go so hard on rhythm games.
It's actually crazy because it's actually crazy impressive
too.
Because I remember like I seeing like some, I think like, I
think like when I was in Asia, like I just see like this guy
who just got out of work.
You tell that he just got out of work and he has like those
professional gloves on for the rhythm games.
And then he would like put his suitcase down and like,
scrunch up his sleeves and stuff put the gloves on and go
yeah I know yeah my my right like I had a friend that had
gloves before like I was just randomly going with her like
just to hang out together and like we just passed by the
arcade actually and she was like hey can we stop by the
arcade for a while and I was like okay no problem I like
games so I was like I went in I didn't play anything i just
watch her go crazy she had like a bag and she she just took
out like these white gloves and i was like oh but you have
gloves and and she had like this big bottle of water as well
just like ready there and she's like crazy so it's like you
have to reduce the friction or just screw your combo oh my
god that's so hardcore it's like when like fps gamers have
to buy like pad because the friction will ruin it's just
like that so surprised because she played like I remember
like at the time I think she was playing osu you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she played osu as well she was like some
top player and I was like oh god she's this girl yeah she
just played like rhythm games only I think like she only
played that's so cool though yeah it was like my first time
because I don't I don't I play a little bit but I don't
really you know go at it that much So I was just like
watching her the entire time.
I think it's also just like it's like super impressive
because it's like like the dedication to and how fast they
go as well.
Like the like how fast your hands go there.
I can't I can't see like my eyes are hurting like I'm just
like oh my god.
How do you know what to what to what to hit?
I think like but like arcades are like so popular in
Indonesia.
Arcades are still very popular.
Like fucking NA, it's like it died out.
Really?
Yeah, there's like barely any arcades in NA now.
Like people are just, people would just be like, why do I
have to play, go play in an arcade when I can just play at
home, you know?
They'll be like, oh, I have PC.
I have my consoles.
Why do I need to go to arcades?
Yeah, a lot of arcades in NA have died out.
But like, I know like, because arcades in NA is like a
children thing.
Like we see it as like four kids.
The games aren't different.
Like, like, are pretty different, maybe.
games as well but like even if they have like some games
that are made for adults like rhythm games and stuff like
that it's just not popular in NA but like in Asia it's like
it's mostly for adults with like a lot of like arcade
machines and like the rhythm games and stuff like that and I
think it's also like you know UFO catchers and stuff yeah I
like UFO catchers I love UFO catchers too but like whenever
I I'm always so sad because I'm like crap I know I should
just buy the item but I can't resist I just want to try I
just want to try a few times and then I fail and I'm like
okay maybe I'll try a few more times and then you'd be like
please you know you ask somebody like please can you help me
ask those at 10 it's like can you make it easier like oh
yeah and also like in NA like we have to have prizes in for
Like you know like tickets and stuff So like if you do well
in arcades Like you get tickets to exchange it for like
prizes But like I know like in Asia arcades You just play
the game Like there's no like actual prizes It's like the
prize is the experience of gaming I think a long time ago
there may have been Like I think it's just different now
Yeah it died out The prize system But yeah because like
there's just like actual good arcade games And stuff Yeah
it's just like you go there and play the actual games and
have fun yeah it's just the experience i'm miss i'm miss ark
and there's like and then there's like some areas where you
have to be like you have to be like 18 or older to like go
in wait really yeah yeah i remember this because i remember
i was like in the i the only reason i remember this is
because i think i was like in i think i was like in like uh
like hong kong airport and then like there was a section
there where you can like um there was like a section the
arcades was like you have to be 18 to go to the arcade
because we have some games that are for adults only I was
like dad I want to go to the arcade and then my dad was like
no you're not 18 you can't you can't go inside and I'll be
like but these games inside yeah because there's like Like
some of the machines, it's like I think it's like It's sort
of like Pachinko You know like Pachinko And stuff But then
they will have like I'm not a fan of Pachinko It's just I
think Yeah I think I mean that's why they're like Cause
there's Pachinko There's like Pachinko machines So they're
like You had no children at all But I don't know if it was
Pachinko I just remembered like They wouldn't let me in
Because they're like She's not 18 So she can't go in And I'm
like, but there's arcade machines.
I see some arcade machines in there.
But you know, you know, Japan has like those large pachinko.
Oh yeah, yeah, no.
It's like all just pachinko.
It's like so popular.
It's crazy.
And then they have like actually really noisy though.
Yeah, and they have like crossovers with like different
animas and stuff too.
I know there was like a Madoka pachinko machine that was
super popular.
I know that...
I know like when I was growing up there was like like
there's like this like children's arcades Because there was
one was like oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh I think like people who uh who live in Hong Kong
will remember this like arcade I think it was like USA
Jumping gym.
I think it was like a popular arcade chain.
I think that was what it's called Maybe it's not.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm butchering the name It was like a super popular
like um arcade like uh arcade place wait let me see maybe
i'm but it's not even called that no it is it's called
jumping gym usa yeah jumping gym usa yeah it was like a
super popular it was like a super uh popular like uh like uh
kids arcade area uh like we're just like prizes and stuff
too yes the rainbow one okay and then it was so funny
because there would be like those coin pusher games it'll be
like you know like the ones where you put a coin in and it
pushes out tokens and stuff and then um because like so i
think it's because like there's there's like no you know
there's no like gambling places and stuff like that and so
like all the grannies all the grandparents and and like
would just be sitting at the coin pushers because it's like
for them it way of like a casino like with the coin pusher.
And I was like and then I would like I would go and be like
yay USA jumping gym.
I can't wait.
I can't wait to play because you can win prizes and there
was like a lot of fun arcade games.
I was really, I was a little kid.
And then all the coin pushers.
And parents can just be there.
And then all the coin pushers were occupied by the
grandparents.
Oh.
I didn't see all these other grandfares just be at the coin
pushers just with like a huge bag of tick Because it's
tickets So they'll have like a huge plastic bag filling up
the tickets and stuff And then they'll have like a
collection of coins just like doing a coin pusher I'll just
be like, but I want to play the coin pusher, too
Yeah, as a kid you don't really know you just want to play
everything I'd be like, I want to play too Yeah.
It was just so interesting.
Like, I would remember every time, because there were
multiple, there were multiple of this, like, the Jumpin' Gym
USA.
And then I would always see, like, like, so many
grandparents just always at the coin pushers every time.
It's just, like, kids and grandparents.
I think you're still at the coin pushers.
like, on one knee.
Like, yeah, I think, Jesus, like, Pachinko and coin pushers
are, like, still really popular it is really popular yeah
like i remember like my grandma won one one me like won my
family a fucking oh is it a rice cooker from yeah yeah the
prizes because like the prizes there like when they do have
prizes they're like like actual like good prizes so there'd
be like like vacuum cleaners because it like encourages
people because they're like oh my god we can actually get
like good stuff like so there'll be like vacuum cleaners
cooking appliances like rice cookers and stuff like that
it'll be like it's like there's like rice cooker kids toys
like there's will be like toys for kids and then there'll be
like like like appliances wait i'll tell you like a story
like i like the have you ever won something before like just
randomly like i won i think the best item i won when i was
like a kid was like a phone I actually want a phone.
Oh, really?
But, but you know what?
I was so young, I was like eight or nine.
Yeah.
And like my parents were like, oh, you don't need that
phone.
You know what?
Dad will use it.
Like my dad will use it for now.
And, and like my phone and like my dad just took it and used
it instead.
I was like, oh.
How did you want the phone?
I just like, I forgot how it was like a lottery or
something.
And like, they're calling people's names.
and it's calling numbers I think and then like my number was
like you got a phone and I was so happy I was like oh my god
I want a phone I gave it to my parents and I you're too
young it's like our phone now your phone no our phone yeah I
was like so sad I was like but phone well I guess I I didn't
get my phone.
No, no phone.
I remember they gave me something else.
They gave me their gift.
I remember their gift is like some wallet or something.
Not as expensive as a phone.
It was like a tiny, tiny one.
It was very tiny.
I was like, oh, nice.
At least you get to hold it for a cup for a little bit.
You know, you need to feel the sense of winning a phone.
I had the box in my hand.
Yeah, yeah, you're like, at least I have that box.
I put it down actually like I went to sleep and then like I
put it on the table and like the next day is gone I was like
where did it go It's like well One day with a phone Yeah I
was like damn Damn At least you got the experience you know
it's all about the experience Yeah I was like, okay, because
I was like rationalizing with myself, I was like, okay,
maybe I am too young to be my parents are right.
You know what?
It's okay.
They can use it.
How old were you when you had your first phone?
Oh, I don't remember.
Damn, I don't remember.
I remember it was like my dad's phone that he gave me.
Oh, yeah.
Like, it was like their, their like, like their secondhand
phone.
when I had my first phone I think Cause like I was like All
like All my friends had phones Like cell phones Oh like My
first phone Was the Uh It was like The I don't know Moto
Motorola Oh You remember that You remember that phone And
then it was like Moto role Like it Seems that funky song I
think I think I saw some Like like Like adults using it
That's why That's the only reason I think Yeah It was like a
hand-me-down.
It was a hand-me-down from my parents.
And then I loved that phone because it would sing the song
was so funny.
That's like, I was like, somebody call me so I can listen to
the song.
Hello, Moto.
Yes.
I was like, it's true.
It would be like, Hello Moto.
It was so good.
I was like, I hope somebody calls me so I can listen to that
song.
like bought like like take my dad's phone i'll just because
like back then i think there's like no games on phones right
those those really yeah back then and like i was like a
little kid yeah snake i will only play snake and there's
like those like uh shoot shooting ones the one like you
control like the plane yeah stuff all the time yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah just like those those two games and just play
it over and over guys we're not old okay guys those were
just had me downs guys we're not old it was just had me
downs yeah i was i was just excited to get a phone i think
in the first yeah me too i was so excited oh my god i got my
own phone guys give me your numbers i have a phone now guys
yeah and and like the first time i had to remember you had
to memorize your own number oh true true huh oh yeah i need
to like memorize my own number now what I was like, what's
your number?
And I'm like, oh, I don't remember.
Let me look at my own context.
Oh, my God.
I love how this is the, this is how we devolved the I try.
Look, we tried.
We tried to speak Chinese.
We tried.
There's some Chinese.
Yeah.
Look, we, we did, we made it up by like talking about like
our, like experiences, like living in China.
Well, my experience is living in China.
I'll tell you one I guess you know what I'll tell you one
Chinese thing now like I guess Just you know Make it seem
like we're dry You have to make it relevant There is like a
meme I don't know how like sensitive Like just like people
are in like And like Western And culture and all that Yeah
You know games with like For example apex or something If
there's like cheaters or something Like for example A
professional is like Caught cheating or something That is
like a big thing Is like Yeah really bad yeah like okay no
why why did you go hacking or something yeah like like
there's like a lot of like memes of that in like chinese the
chinese community for like those kind of people it's like
how it's like a really funny one okay no there's no it's
like all funny by the way okay it's like totally like it
just devolves into like okay okay we they just like uh of
course it's like a bit bad but like most of it is just like
laughing at the person all the time and it's mostly because
like um there's like a guy who was like chai jiu du leian he
was like if you're if you're chai is like if you're like bad
at some like bad at the game yeah just practice more he's he
was saying he was like but he was hacking by the way so yeah
yeah so so he was like a professional And he's just like,
oh, just just practice more, but he was a hacker.
It's like, it's like, you can't like take losing, don't
play.
Oh, you're a hacker.
It's really famous, actually.
And it was because he was doing some weird hand gestures and
stuff.
He looked like a crab, by the way.
You've practiced.
So it's basically like, get good.
Yeah.
It was because, like, I think he was like playing
competition or something.
something and like in the first half he was getting beaten
really badly and like in the second half he was killing
everybody so everyone was like wait wait a minute that's a
hacker and then he said that he was like yeah it's like it
was like some whole big statement it was really funny that's
so funny it is like i was just like get good yeah yeah and
there's another one like i think not that old as well like
maybe late last year yeah late last year as well which
became really big because it was it was actually a youtuber
by the way that did it um it was like a tournament for
valorant wait i heard about that did you hear like yeah it
It was like people overseas her talked about it too It was
so bad It became a meme though Because it was really funny
Everybody started like streaming with like a box on your
screen Like a box because it was like the hack she was using
So yeah it was like The clowns just a lot Like like what is
this square It's like Whoa what is this square It's just
like Clara Okay because like people Okay the reason why like
people overseas knew about it is because we had a similar
instance with like Clara so like it's a I don't have you
heard about the Clara meme okay so like the reason why we
knew about it is because like in an NA we had a similar
experience with like but like it wasn't tournament or
anything but it was like this girl that was like she's
playing CS go and then and then basically it's it's so
similar it's so that showed her her walling and stuff and
then people in her stream were like Wait, what the fuck
she's hacking and then she was like she noticed and then she
was like, oh my god It's Clara Clara installed Clara was on
my PC and installed hacks onto my PC Clara, what did you do
Clara?
But obviously people were like who the fuck is Clara?
So she tried to like blame this fucking made-up girl named
Clara That...
Yeah.
It was like similar.
I think because of that, like people just put a box on your
screen the whole time and she was like, Oh, what is this
box?
Wait.
What is this box?
Oh, it can't move.
Why is it moving with the people?
I think she said it was like because of her setting or like
she was doing some preset.
It was like a visual setting.
Like a preset?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was like a preset.
And Erin was like, oh, no.
Yeah.
Preset.
Oh, my God.
That's actually...
People who...
I don't understand why would you hack, though, in a video
game?
I think it's better to just admit that...
Yeah, just be bad.
Just end it.
Like, go.
Just leave.
I think if you defend yourself, like...
You can't defend yourself if you, like...
You can't defend yourself.
Yeah, you can.
You'll be known as a hacker.
Yeah.
So, so most, most, like, hacker, like, like, those, like,
big, like, or like people who are vtuber who you know who
just like hack it just becomes memes yeah yeah it is oh like
destroyer it's funny you remember like you saw destroy the
apex hack that was happening in tournament tournament yeah
yeah and then the guy i saw yeah i was watching it live it's
actually crazy how that guy yeah that guy like hacked like
how i think the funniest part was when you know like Jen
burning got hacked and then he like instantly left the game
and then when how I don't know you saw it but when how got
hacked I was watching yeah yeah how got hacked he was like
he said he said I'm hacked and and and then he shot he kept
shooting guys he's like what if I don't shoot guys and then
he can't shoot it it was really funny though it was so funny
he's like he's like guys I'll just don't shoot and it's
killed two people
but like it's just the fact that like um the guy who like
hacked was just there to be like it's crazy though the guy
that hacked like did you read more about it like he just
wanted to like like be public about it to like the apex devs
and was like hey guys like you guys need to fix this like
it's so he's like yeah i didn't really know i just heard
about like yeah he did it video basically he did it for like
competition publicity because he only did it for attention
like like he because he's done it before he's like hacked
people he's he's only hacked pro players to like reveal like
security issues and he was like advertising yeah he was i
was like oh here's some security issues and like anyway i
did that like and it was just for publicity crazy yeah yeah
it's about sending a message yeah well yeah there's a lot of
things that needs to be fixed though thank god yes true
oh my god i like apex i like apex too yeah but you know
sometimes sometimes it needs to be fixed oh 100 there's like
like oh my gosh I got like um I told my chat this but like
like I get like sneak peeks for like what's gonna happen for
like next seasons and stuff but like it's so hard to keep
the thing secret because I actually when I almost leaked out
the solos mode like one month before it came I almost leaked
it out on stream because like um I was in a tournament I was
in an apex tournament And then we were joking about like Oh
man, like Soon you can 1v1 people soon And then as I was
like Oh yeah, solos I was like Oh wait, I can't say that I
can't talk about solos modes coming back I can't say it Oh,
is it like you're just chatting And then like you're not
thinking Yeah, I'm not thinking Because I knew like I was
like Oh yeah, solos mode Because I knew about the solos mode
that's coming out And then like Think about it and your
mouth just opens Yeah, I'll just be like Sholo Oh, be funny
Ha ha
It's crazy Yeah, I'm also scared Like if I knew something I
think it'll be really hard to keep it to myself I just have
to not think about it The stuff I know for next season Wow
God Okay Don't worry.
I'll cover your voice in line.
In case you say anything.
In next season 22, there's going to be...
Crazy.
Scary.
That's so scary.
Oh god.
It's okay.
I didn't leak anything though.
I didn't leak anything.
It just almost slipped out because like it was just...
The solo mode thing was like...
It was just right there.
I almost forgot I never It didn't exist Did you get to play
Alter like New like Apex just update it right?
Yeah yeah I gotta play Alter.
I think Alter is a team A team character.
She's so bad at Solos mode.
I hate playing her in Solos She has no mobility She has no
mobility other than the portal So yeah I was playing her
yesterday.
I played her For a while and then I stopped And now, and
then Ariana's asking, Hey, why aren't you playing the new
hero?
I was like, I don't want to play.
I'm done.
You're just like, I'm done playing with you.
I went back to Rafe.
I was like, okay.
I think she's really good for team fights.
Apparently she's really good for rank and stuff.
Because if you're a very aggressive team, she's really good
because you can like get to places and do team fights.
She's basically like, you know, like the Octane Rev jump pad
thing.
I like her.
like her very much it's just like i was like playing her
every single day yeah i gotta i gotta change it up for a bit
i have like do you know i have like a problem with valkyrie
actually like i played her i think in the first season i got
master like solo master yeah i used valkyrie to play because
at the time i think it was like i forgot which season it was
but like everybody like playing solo was like hell because
everybody just kept like uh dying even Immediately like
going and just ice.
Yeah, so you just play Val can just fly away.
Yeah, I would just fly away and I'm like, bye.
I'm going rat now.
But because I played her so much, I got like sick of her.
Yeah, no, that's true.
And I haven't played her until today.
And it's been like two years.
Oh my gosh.
It's true.
Like you just get tired of playing the same character.
You just want some variety too.
Yeah.
Say that in Chinese because it's a...
Chinese.
Yeah, say that in Chinese.
say what in chinese say that say talk about valcon chinese
do you wait do you know her name in chinese her official
name is war jili it's just yeah yeah and what do you what do
you what's the nickname but but i call her just just flying
lady flying lady fey nuren fey nuren just yeah it's just
flying lady i just flying lady i just call it flying lady
Yeah.
What's the Chinese name for Apex Legends again?
No.
Wait.
Actually, people don't really call it.
Like, you know what they call it?
What do you call it?
Usually, usually what I call it and what I've seen people
call it is just...
Hi.
Hi?
Hi or hi?
Hi.
Hi?
It's just like hi?
Oh, like, oh wait, what?
Why hi?
Hi.
Hi, it's like...
Uh...
I forgot why it's pi.
It's like... It's like da pi, you know?
It's like...
I forgot.
Wait, wait, wait.
This thing is like... I really don't remember, but like,
I'll type it for you.
The actual word.
This...
Pi.
I think it's because it's called...
In Chinese.
They call it A as well.
Just A.
Just the letter A.
It's cute.
I think it's just a name Apex, A-Py Oh, A-Py?
Oh, that would have Yeah, I think it's just a name And it's
just like shorter Like I like I like Pie Is that what they
say?
You want to play?
Yeah, You want to play?
Yeah, Yeah, You want to play?
Just to play It's also like Playing cards I think or
something like that It's also like Like, like Pepe Pie Yeah,
yeah, so So, so Like, they just call it Like Dapy It's just
also oh i see i see that makes sense yeah look i'm learning
guys see we're learned i'm learning chinese and i'm trying
to speak chinese and i said that in english all right you
you guys you guys i'm going to speak but i'm i'm going to
say i'm going to say you know you're a newbie yeah you're in
the newbie my newbie is newbie newbie you're like newbie
it's like noob Right?
It's a new?
No.
Oh, wait.
Where is it?
I thought you called me a newbie.
No.
Wait, what did you say?
Okay, newbies is kind of like...
Okay, the translation is bad, but the meaning is good.
You know what I mean?
Oh, okay.
Like...
Um, new...
New...
It's like cow...
Anyway, it's a private part of the cow.
Okay, just...
What?
Yeah.
Wait, why did you call me a cow?
It's either the other or it's the other.
It's the other, like the milking.
The thing is the other.
I think it's that.
Or it's the other one, which I'm not going to say.
Oh, wait, but why did you call my Chinese that?
No, it means it's good in Chinese though.
Nube is me.
Means it's like amazing.
Oh, so you're saying my chat.
I know.
My chat.
Yeah.
Is are you like gaslighting me?
Are you?
No, it's true.
It's true.
Wait, it's actually true.
Okay.
I had to be sure.
Because I'm like, They like to say newbie.
I actually have no idea why.
This is like something I'm taught as well.
And I'm like, wait, why do you guys like to say newbie?
I don't even know why.
But like, but like it's it it just it does mean it's you're
like it's it's great something is great so you can say like
like you need to don't a newbie or you know like you play
apex really well you know it's like that a lot of like curse
words become like good words as well I can I can I can So
you know There I think there's One more It's like Yeah So
There's a They like to use English Like Sounding Like
English words That sound Like something else In Chinese as
well Yeah like What Oh Can I Can I use a Can I Can I teach
you A curse one A curse word Wait Oh okay But how curse It's
like So it's this I'm gonna put it in chat it's it's not bad
bad what i mean that's what they like to see i guess taught
this can you try and think of it in your head and like and
wait but what does it mean wait what what does it mean it's
not worse than than than taonima so don't worry what does
that mean
The word, the sentence is like Funny Mud Go Pea.
Funny Mud Go Pea.
But if you use like a Chinese accent or say it, it's like
Funny Mud Goa Oh!
Wait, I don't!
I know that word!
You know?
I know.
I know because I've heard it in a movie.
I've heard it.
I read it in a movie And then I'd be like Mom what's that
word And then I would be like we know It's a bad word You
know like I've been like watching Movie and then they say
some very bad Words I'd be like dad What are they saying
like it's a very Bad word Yeah yeah it's It's interesting
because like it's You know when like like to like trick i
don't know why but like they like to play pranks basically
it's not really a harmful one it's just like they like to
say they put something in english and you're like don't know
what it is so you're like you read it out loud and people
are like hey don't say that it's like when when people are
like how do you say corn in cantonese and then i'll be like
i'm not stupid so stupid okay so like okay okay okay guys
you didn't got me you didn't got me okay it's an English
joke but they use Cantonese to make you say it but like
basically it's like in Cantonese to say corn is so my and
then they'll be like suck my nuts you know
So they're like, they're like, oh, you know Cantonese?
How do you say corn in Cantonese?
And they'll be like, oh my god, suck my nuts.
Ha ha, got him.
Oh, I get it.
So it's like similar to that joke.
Yeah, it is.
It is actually.
It's really funny, though.
Like, these kind of things are so interesting.
Holy shit.
Languages are so funny.
I know.
That's why you know.
so many languages.
You know Dito, right?
Like she taught she taught me.
I think Nachan and I both like some like curse words.
Oh, some Thai curse words?
Oh no, she taught me too.
Yeah.
I have like another friend that knows Thai and I was like,
hey, I know Thai now.
And she was like, oh, where, how did you learn Thai?
I was like, my friend taught me.
And then I said those curse words to her.
She was like, She...
If you're in public, by the way, and she was like...
What the hell would you just say?
It's like...
I'm not in public!
Yeah, it was really...
It was really bad.
And she had to hide her face.
She was hiding her face already.
She's like...
Stop!
No!
I don't know you!
I like...
Knowing lots of languages is really great.
You just like...
Oh, yeah.
it's really funny especially like when you go into public
and then like somebody's talking in a different language
that they think people don't understand and they're like
gossiping and then you like that happened oh my god no it
was bro i okay i had like a negative experience with that i
was like i like embarrassed like some fucking mom at like my
school so like i i don't remember where i think like i was
just eating at a cafeteria and then like um i I think like
like the mom and the child like the mom came over to give a
lunch to like one of the kids and then like they didn't
realize I can speak Cantonese so then she like was gossiping
about like oh I think she was like gossiping about my food
or something because like I don't know maybe I had like my
food look bad or something and then she was gossiping about
it and then in Cantonese and then I turned around and I was
like oh I know what you're talking about and then she got
instantly left.
Like she was so embarrassed and then like, left.
I was like, Wow!
The instant was like, what's today going on?
Yeah.
That must be so embarrassing, though.
I would die of embarrassment, honestly, if that was me, too.
I was like, bro, what the fuck?
Yeah!
It's really funny.
It's actually really useful.
It's like, you just Assume like you don't know and like
you're like I know Just don't know and then they're like
saying like gossiping in front of you too And then you're
just like bro, what the fuck?
I'm just eating
It's like if you're going to gossip in a different language
Make sure they don't understand or you get roasted hard Like
maybe don't gossip in front of people Like don't you'll
never know they actually know Your language and the grandmas
and oh yeah yeah love the costume especially like if they
think like the person doesn't know the language they'll just
be like it's like oh you know like how like okay like my mom
does this sometimes like you know like if somebody like in
front of like if there's like someone that did something and
they didn't like it and they'll like straight up be like oh
my god this person right in front of them in a different
language and then like they'll just be like They must be
saying something nice about me.
Yeah.
It's so, it's really awkward when they're like speaking, for
example, like we're speaking English one moment and suddenly
they switch to like, to say, they switch language to like
Cantonese or Chinese or something.
You're like, okay, they're definitely saying something bad,
I think.
Oh my gosh.
Um, I think I remember like, like, I remember like, but
sometimes like, because like, I don't know, like in
Cantonese, sometimes like, like Cantonese it sounds like
we're talking like super harshly but like it's just like a
normal like we're just having a normal conversation and I
remember like I was like I think I was like like talking to
my parents about something like something like oh like oh
what do I want to eat or something and then like I think my
friend was like are you guys arguing like why does this
sound like like are you guys okay like and I was like yeah I
was just ordering food and they're like oh I thought you
guys were arguing about something like no we're just we're
just ordering
and chinese does sound like i think if you don't know the
language it sounds a little bit like aggressive but actually
it's just it's just how you say the words yeah it's just
like the tonal intonation yeah yeah yeah yeah it just sounds
aggressive people who don't understand it's just it's just
yeah i think certainly other like yeah i think other
languages as well like you just don't understand what
they're saying but it just sounds aggressive but actually
it's they're like talking about like totally normal things
yeah is actually it's so funny when people like who don't
understand are just like are they arguing i'm like no i'm
just having a conversation like oh my god have you ever
watched any like uh chinese movies like like animation like
pop culture chinese movies oh pop culture chinese dudes like
like like famous ones because i was like thinking do you
know about matau or matau but i think that's because it's
but matau is like more hong kong though it's like really
popular in hong kong what what's that you know matau matau
is like it's like a story about pig um and oh it's like it's
like i i like i know because like i sort of like grew up
with matau and it's like uh um it's like talking about like
uh like he is talking about like a pig pig growing up way
and like growing up in Hong Kong and it's like the it's like
super memorable because it has uh because it has like a very
memorable song and also like there was a scene about
ordering food and stuff but like I think it might be too
it's just like I don't know if I don't think you would know
it's not old it's not everything I say is old okay so is it
too Because I don't know Cantonese.
Yeah.
I know it's like, it's also popular, like, it's very popular
in Hong Kong, but I know that it's also popular outside of
Hong Kong, but I don't know if you've watched it before.
It's not old.
It's pretty old to be on.
No, it's not!
Stop saying it's old!
This is it!
The last movie was in 2016, guys!
Whoa, eight years ago!
Okay, the first movie was in 2001, but like, you don't...
Wait, that's like...
Oh, God, that's not...
It's not...
Oh!
I have not.
I have not seen that.
You know, I honestly...
It's a good movie.
I actually...
I think it's...
I think it was a really good childhood movie.
I didn't watch it in theaters.
I watched it on the DVD.
When my parents bought me a DVD Okay guys, it's not that old
When I watched it VIP seats again I didn't even get to watch
it in the theaters I watched it as a DVD Because I was not
old enough to watch it in the theaters
DVD boomer Who can Like who watches DVDs anymore?
DVD DVD Yeah, I haven't seen a DVD in here That's so true
That's true, true My PC doesn't even have a CD or DVD slot
anymore Like They stop that Yeah, they stop that in solo I
don't know I also don't know Like I think Uh I think I still
had Like anime DVDs Oh I I I Was like Into anime When I was
young too Yeah But like I didn't know What anime is what And
you know There's like A lot of those like Like Like Suss
ones Right Like Yeah Like Yeah Like You know One guy A
hundred girls Kind of anime Like Oh yeah That's pretty sus
Yeah that's pretty sus I don't know those kinds Cause I'm
Really I I am here.
It was, it's not like, it's not like R18, but you know,
it's, it was like kind of like, whoa, you know, like the
body would come, like, suddenly come up.
And like, and like, I was like, I remember there was like
DVD and I was like really young at the time.
And then like, I was, I would go with my mom to like look at
the DVD.
And like, we bought, like, we bought one and it was, I think
I can say the name.
It was like a Rosario vampire.
Do you know that?
I don't know I don't think so because I think Rosario but
maybe I know the picture maybe wait I'm gonna It was it was
it was a Rosario vampire And I did I thought It looked like
very cute at first Because I was like oh it's a pink hair
girl It looks so nice Oh it looks cute yeah Okay so I got
tricked by the cover of it Like there's nothing weird about
the cover by the way So I bought it And like took it home
and like I was watching it with my mom by the way and like I
was sitting there and like and like the first I think the
first episode or something the guy like fell into the girl's
like chest and I and my mom was like oh god no oh no oh no
oh no yeah it was like it was like it was like crazy and and
like and like my mom immediately like stopped the like DVD
and she was like okay when you're older you can watch this
And then I was like, oh, why?
Why?
Why can't I watch it?
I just bought it.
And she was like, this is not for kids.
Yeah.
I got stopped.
Oh, no.
You stay here for a little longer.
Yeah, but then I secretly went with my, like, grandfather to
buy, like, another DVD.
Oh, my God, they watched it.
But I bought a different one this time.
I bought Chobits.
By the way.
Wait, is it Chobits also?
Chobits, but I never watched it, but is it also similar?
It just looked cute!
It does look cute!
Like, honestly?
Chobits looks so, like, the girl, like, Chi, her name is
Chi, and she looked very cute on the cover, and I was like,
oh, this is so cute!
And I bought it as well, and and, like, I started watching
it, I was like, no!
Oh, no!
What does this mean?
It's... Whoa!
What is she doing?
I knew, like, oh, God, they're showing their body again.
I'm trying to let my mom find out.
But yeah.
Yeah, so I was like, I was like, what does this mean?
And then I looked it up.
Oh my gosh, the beach episode.
Oh no.
Every day was the beach episode.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, that reminded me.
You know, like the famous, oh my gosh, I don't know how to
pronounce it with the...
Let me Google this real fast.
There's like the famous dance, the caramel...
Is it the caramel dance?
Oh, can you know the Caramela dance?
Oh, wait.
You know that dance, right?
You know the origin of that dance, right?
Yeah.
I found that out recently.
Okay, for those who don't know, the dance, the origin of
that dance is...
It's not.
It's 18 plus.
Let's just say.
really yeah wait really i didn't know that wait what did you
know i just knew about the cute the the one that they dance
all the time they're just dancing the old the old video
where the girls are just dancing the origin of it was that
the dance came from a porn game it is wait really yes i
found out i found out like a couple of months ago because
people were like talking it was like do you guys remember
this dance oh sorry a porn visual novel which thank you for
correcting me yeah it is yeah it was like the opening scene
for like the opening intro for that game people someone was
like it's so weird that people like took that dance when the
origin of the game when the game I look so innocent like in
the video I saw like they did you just doing like a cute
little dance I'm like yeah like really yeah no I'm yeah I'm
about to google caramel dance in origin you know caramel
dance in origin yeah it is wait of like like my my like
experience with it is kind of like gone right now it's like
i thought it was really cute i just thought it was cute now
i'm thinking damn i got it well this is the i'm not going i
mean my mod one i don't know if my mod should like like like
give the name of the this is the visual novel.
This is a visual novel.
If I Google that, is it...
Someone in my chat was like, it's caught in... What's it
called?
Eroge?
Wait.
Yeah, Eroge.
It's like uncultured, girl.
Oh my god!
There's safe search.
My Google Chrome is telling me you safe search.
Your girl was like, it's trying to save you.
They're like, I don't know.
It's trying to blur.
Safe search is on.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Okay.
Wait, but it looks so cute.
Is this an arrow?
Really?
Yeah.
It looks so cute, though.
No, I was, I, I, for my research purposes, yes, it is not,
it's not just that.
I was like, there's no way.
Just like you.
just like you i was innocent impure and i was like there's
no way and then i looked further and i was like oh wait no
that's so but it looks so innocent like the first few images
totally it looks normal it just looks like it just looks
like an old anime wait it's the same character designer as
the monogatari series wait really oh my god wait i think
it's Oh my god, it is!
It's the same character designer!
Oh my god.
Did you watch Monogatari?
No, no, I didn't.
But like, I know about the show.
And it was like super famous.
Do you know there's like a tongue twister in that one?
I really like that.
Oh, this is a cat one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me try.
Can you see it?
I know I cannot see it.
I'm pretty sure I butchered that.
I remember I used to be able to do it.
I don't know if I can do it now.
Oh my god.
Oh and then you replaced all the...
Oh yeah, you replaced all the nads with nya.
Nya, nya, nya, nya.
Nya yamen yan yan yan yan yan yan I cannot do it I cannot do
it You should be able to do it because you're a cat A cat
girl I mouth We've been like chatting I'm like In like an
English thing Like for me I'm like going like When I'm
talking English Like my brain is like Fully in English And
I'm going to talk in Chinese I'm talking fully in Chinese
I'm fully in Japanese.
Actually, I can't multitask, you know?
I'm really bad at multitasking.
Oh, me too.
I'm so bad at multitasking.
Like, I tried before to, like, multitask and I just failed.
I was like...
Oh, no.
Wait, what did you try to do?
No.
Like, anything.
Like, whenever I tried multitask, I just, like...
I can't.
I just can't.
I need to, like, focus.
Yeah.
Yeah!
I have a bad...
Do you know, I used to have a really bad habit?
Like, I would actually do that, by the way.
Like, unironically.
Just be like...
Just have that cat accent.
Like, unironically, not even a VTuber, by the way.
Like, during...
Like, I don't buy.
Just, like, out in public, and you're like, you want to do
this?
Yeah!
Yeah, it was...
Like, that!
It's really bad!
You did it, you did it!
You did the thing!
I had, I like trained myself to like stop it basically
because it was really embarrassing.
Like a lot of times.
Because the old said, did you just, did she just meow?
Like...
Yeah!
And, and yeah, I, it was really, really bad like before I
went to Billy Billy as well.
But I, yeah, it was really, really bad.
I know your chat loves it though.
Your chat would be like, do it again!
I was like, She did the thing!
Yeah, but I did my best to like stop myself because it
was...
I would end my sentence with like...
Like, nia as well sometimes.
Like, not even thinking, by the way.
It was really bad.
Like, I don't know why.
What was...
What happened to me?
Yeah, you just couldn't help yourself.
Yeah, it was just like...
Nia!
Oh no!
It happens when I'm like, when I'm like not thinking, by the
way, that's a problem.
Oh my god.
She's looping.
She was looping.
Let's change the cat.
Let's change.
Let me not say yes.
Return the cat.
As we, you know, we've been, we've been talking for three,
more than three hours.
How much Chinese have we talked?
Look, that's not the important part here.
Okay.
We don't look at percentages, okay?
We don't look at the percentages and the stats here.
Try to fight you have first.
My title said, I try, and I did try.
I tried so high.
You're supposed to train me to talk in Chinese more.
No, use a little bit of English.
We're going to start using English.
I'm sorry about what's learning it to have been In Chinese!
I also say, I'm a lot.
No, no, I'm a whiter.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whiterer means like, like shit.
You know, it's like, oh crap.
No!
It's like, uh, how do you say it?
It's like, it's like a, it's like a less like, like, like,
like curse, curse, curse way of like things.
No!
I got it.
No.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm a Chinese.
I have an accent.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
I say that when something goes, like if something goes
wrong, you can say like, Like it's bad.
You know, it's bad.
It's broken.
It basically means it's like broken, but it's not really, it
doesn't mean broken.
You know, it's just like, oh, damn.
What's learning again in Chinese?
I Cher Cher is like !
Cher si is like Yeah I sure Swear si la Am I pronounced it
correctly?
Cher si Je治 lang Cher si Chinese
Yippee Yippee Okay Okay Okay Okay Okay I can do it I can say
Go You know Go Go Go Good enough Go Good Okay That's good
It's good enough Like Go Go Go Go Yeah Yeah Cantonese is
like gola gola gola gola yeah let's see wait you can
understand Cantonese right a little bit okay whatever like
can we have a conversation where you speak Chinese and I
speak Cantonese really let's just try okay let's see oh well
let's see how are you You today...
What are you saying?
Um...
You today, what did you eat?
Uh...
I forgot.
I actually forgot.
I don't know.
You've never eaten anything?
Today?
I remember today.
Today...
I was like number one I was like number one like you
remember that I'm still trying to I'm still trying to try to
listen to your you're listening to me I really don't know
you're not listening to me you're listening to me I'm
thinking how to say that it's very very hard very hard You
know what I'm saying?
I know what I know what you're saying.
I know what you're saying.
Just think about what you're saying.
You're saying what you're saying, I'm going to think.
And I'm going to say what I'm going to think about how to do
it.
My, my, my, my, my, my, my, my head, my head, my head.
And then, we have to think about English, and we have to
think about how to think about English.
And we have to think so many things together.
Oh my god, I didn't hear you.
What?
Okay, I'm...
I'm talking to you.
I'm going to listen to you.
I'm going to think about it.
I'm going to think about English.
And I'm just thinking, do you know what I'm saying?
Because I'm saying it very fast.
He's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's
like, he's like, he's like, he's like, I'm in the middle,
halt.
But you can't.
Say, you say, you say, you say, we're not doing it.
It's the way you're doing it.
You're doing it, you're saying very quickly.
And I'm saying what?
Yes, yes.
Okay, so you know what you're saying?
You know what I'm saying.
What?
Just another one.
That one.
Back then, that I just said what you said?
D.
I'm... I don't know!
I'm asking, I'm talking...
You know?
Do you know what I'm saying?
I don't know...
Oh, you...
I'm not...
I'm not... I'm not...
Say, Cantonese, I'm not...
This, this...
Quantum其實, I...
.
Oh, that's why I'm saying...
I'm... I'm...
Because I'm...
Because I'm not going to...
I'm...
oh
yeah you know you know like uh it is help me yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i always said Yeah,
yeah yeah, yeah I'm saying It's hard It's hard Yeah, we are
okay Oh, yeah Yeah, I think it's the It's like It's the most
Yeah, ha ha ha You're like a You're like, I really I really
can't I just little bit I'm just a little You know, I'm like
I'm a little bit more listening to you.
I think I'm going to hear more than you hear me.
But is it, is it you want to say a bit of the Chinese?
I've said... I've said a lot.
I've said a lot.
I said a lot, what?
You... you... you...
what?
I've said a lot.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's a bit.
You shared a thing.
You tell me, you today.
I shared a...
A...
A-S-A-W-S-L.
I still- See, see, see, see, see, you can, you can, you can,
I can, I can.
A-W-S-L...
Oh, I'm.
I'm gonna die you can, you can, you can show can show, I
know, I know I know fencing you okay okay, no problem no,
no, no, no, no fencing is, is I I don't remember I don't
remember From Discord, how'd it be?
Oh wait, is it?
You don't know?
I know, I know, G...
G-Z-Z-Z-Z-N!
G-Z-G-G-N-N-N-
Yeah, it's fencing with you.
G-Z-N-N-N-N- I don't know
No This guy Okay No no no no no This is 1v1 me 1v1 you Dijon
Dijon What is it?
Dada Dada Dada?
I make my own tongue twister I make my own tongue twister
You don't know Japanese, don't you?
No.
Wait, no!
Murasaki armor.
Murasaki...
Oh, I understand.
I did it!
Murasaki armor.
Yeah!
That's all I mean.
I know the I know the important information Do you want to
know what like Like he's one in Chinese?
Oh wait wait what is it?
Like is he is he is he is Oh wait one one Yeah he's just one
Yeah he's one It's not really that's but like It's basically
that's the you know I see I see Oh my gosh you guys Don't
trust that by the way if you ever hear that It's never It's
never fun.
The same in English too.
There was somebody's name that was like, he's one.
And it's, okay.
Oh yeah, I'll type it out.
It's actually so funny.
I saw someone's name.
He's, it's like, he's one.
And then, quote, I mean, I hit him once.
And it's like, that's like my favorite.
And that's one of my favorite names.
Yeah, it's actually, actually it's the same in Chinese too.
It's like It's like
It's not that he's 1, he's 3 I hit him once I just hit him a
little bit I remember like I said that once I was like Or
it's like Or it's like Or it's like I was like I'm like I am
the one that's like almost dead Oh my god I remember like I
said this once Like I was like He's 1 And then like And then
like I think it was on stream before a long time.
And then my friend was like, well, you mean he's one.
He was fully, he was like 40 HP.
And I was like, he's one bullet.
He's one headshot.
He was one.
It's one headshot.
That's so funny.
Very like, like, like the, like the, he's one in all
languages.
Yeah.
like honestly the same I think so it's like one Krabber
headshot
one Krabber headshot he's one he's one he's one one Krabber
headshot oh yeah I had a great I have fun time oh my god we
fucking yeah talk for so long we yeah going to flat I have I
do have another collab like this is it you know that game I
don't know if You know, it's like, like on Steam now, I
think it's abiotic factor, that one.
Abiotic factor?
Is it the one that's like content creation, but what is it?
It's, it's like, uh, half-life a little bit, I think.
Oh, and maybe I'm not talking about the same game.
It was another game that came out that was like, um, that
was like the content.
Uh, oh my gosh, what was that content game we played?
Content warning you mean?
Yeah, yeah, there was a game that was like, Look, my brain
is not doing so well right now.
Abiotic factor.
I never heard about that game.
What is that game?
Yeah, it's like, yeah, I'm about to play it tonight.
I had no idea as well.
And I don't know.
Oh, like the survival crafter.
Oh, it's a survival game.
Yeah, I don't know.
It was I don't know.
I don't know what it's about.
But like, apparently it's a little bit like lethal company
and like content it's not really like content warning it's
like yeah a little bit lethal company but like half-life
inspired or something like that oh wait that's so cool if
it's half-life inspired but if it's like i don't know i'm
reading it's like a survival crafter so i feel like it's
like a game that you're supposed to play longer than one
time survival half-life yeah survival it's interesting
though yeah it sounds interesting yeah i'm gonna be
collabing that later with
Where you guys be playing again?
Not sure.
I'm big again.
Usually, for us, we're like, you know, for me at least,
like, me and, like, my closer friends on Patreon, we're
like, we're just like, okay, we'll play it, and we'll see
what time we end, kind of thing.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, but, like, when's your collab?
Oh, it's like, it's like at 8, but I'm gonna go eat
something.
Oh, you should go eat it.
Yeah.
I had a great time.
and yapping with you, Hiro.
Yeah, we talked.
I didn't even, it did not feel like almost four hours, to be
fair.
I did not feel like I was talking for four hours.
Chatting.
Just chatting, chatting.
Yeah, just chatting.
It's nice to just chat.
We didn't click.
We didn't clickbait.
We had a very long conversation like 10 minutes ago.
So that's our, that's the content.
Guys, there was no clickbait here.
We did try.
We did.
We did!
We did talk.
We tried so hard.
Like...
Our brain is like...
Our brain right now is overheating.
Qua.
Wait, what?
Qua?
Qua.
Wait, what does it mean?
Please praise me.
Yeah, yeah.
Qaqwa, Qawa, Qawa.
Qawa, Qawa.
Yeah.
You can try it cute.
Say it cutely.
Okay, no, you go first.
I can do that too Yes,
let's all say thank you the hero For being a great teacher
And like bring me up to date because i'm not old i'm not
auntie i'm not an auntie i'm i'm young i'm young no thank
you for chatting with me we should play something you know
i'm we're like nasha and i are but wait did you know dito
dito nasha and i were watching the a lgs oh yes i saw you
guys were watching yeah we're gonna play apex tomorrow oh
yeah the new season the new season we should play sometimes
yeah yeah we sure we should yeah we should play something
again soon yeah it was great talking to you yeah thank you
so much yeah thank you for joining for accepting me invite
to just talk of course of course yeah every time is like
they're having a conversation about like random things and
like i hope you learned a lot about animals i did i learned
cantonese actually yeah and the cantonese too i hope you
learned a lot about cantonese language and also a lot about
pandas i love pandas i learned about rats too yeah and rats
too
thank you for your respect we should like we should visit a
zoo one day just to look at pandas together just be like we
learned so much about you guys sure i'm down you know yeah
just go just go to visit a zoo somewhere just to see the and
be like, this is how we bonded.
God, God, they're stupid.
Oh yeah, and sunbears.
We should see a sunbear together.
Grab like a giant cutout of us and just put them next to
the...
Do you think the zoos will let us bring a cutout of us?
Like a life-size cutout and we just put it...
Like our 2D.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
yeah just just put it there just with the sun bear and the
panda i'll be like oh my god pandas you looks you're so
stupid but you're so cute god i wish it doesn't scare the
animal
all right but yes let's all say goodbye to hero and thank
you for teaching thank you no thank you Bye-bye.
Yeah, let's chat again sometime.
Let's chat again sometime.
My brain is like mush right now.
I don't even know how to do an outro.
Here, do my outro for me.
Do your outro for you?
What do you want me to do?
I don't know.
How do you do your outros?
Use your outro for my stream.
Really?
Yeah.
You want me to do my outro?
My outro kind of.
Like, okay.
Okay, at first I'll thank for like, Thank you for the super,
super like all the super chat.
Thanks for the gifts and thanks for the members and all
that.
And then I'll give them a little kiss though.
Okay, yeah, yeah, do it.
Come on.
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
And doing Chinese because like doing, do it out.
Yeah, okay.
Thank you, XC.
Thank you, Liu Wu.
Thank you, Jin Zhang.
Jin Zhang is what they call it, like captain.
Yeah.
And then, thank you guys for today's video.
Thank you for watching.
Please do follow Doki.
Wow!
That's me!
Yeah!
It's me!
Wow!
You still have chin.
I want.
Because I'm a chin.
Oh, why?
You do it.
Why do I do it?
Because it's your job.
Oh, shit, do you right?
No, that's true!
Okay, guys.
I'll do a countdown, everybody.
Alright, guys.
3, 2, 1.